Hmm.
Mm, mm, mm, mm, mm, mm.
And we're going live.
Yes sir.
[inaudible] your social media people
love you, Bro. People love you too. Oh,
we're live. We're doing it right
now. So we've, we've uh, God, Oh,
what's the word? Gawked what's the word
when you are gold over someone's body?
Sure. Dude, you got jacked.
Skinny to shredded. Yeah. Yep.
You're pretty serious about MMA training,
man.
It's really just about like the lifestyle,
you know what I mean?
You're a martial artist, so, you know,
freak in the mind and the body
and the soul go together. So yeah,
for sure. These things I'm
learning about them. Um,
I'm able to put them all together.
You can't be a complete person until
everything is together. So, um, you know,
spiritually I've already
ascended above my peers.
Now I'm taking my body up there.
How are you doing spiritually
through that giant jug?
A weed you got on the table.
Exactly. Yeah. They have. Yeah.
For the folks who only listen with his,
brought literally like a mason jar
held with we. Yeah. Yup, Yup, Yup.
It is like halfway for a
specific strains that you like.
They asked smoke the KK Khalifa
Kush. Oh, you've got your
own shit. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
absolutely. Because I got tired of
smoking or different types of weed. Um,
it's like a drink. You know
what I'm saying? Like alcohol,
people only drink dark liquor. Whiskey
or I only smoke cocaine. Only take care.
Yup. If you mix it up though,
you'll get a big hit. Right.
Have you switch it up to somebody
else's stuff? You're like woo,
the body's not ready for it. In my head
will go crazy. Like I'll really feel it.
You'll see me like over in the
cornerstone, so I only have this smoke.
KK, that's it. That's the weird
thing about, we'd write it like you,
you get used to a certain strain.
Yeah.
Like I'll get physically like
ill if I don't smoke my strain,
I'll get runny nose coughing. Yeah. Yeah.
I need an Ekka. Wow. Yeah. Yup.
How much do you smoke a day?
Probably a ounce. Like the cool
is we burned in the cooldowns.
How about you? I don't
smoke that much. Yeah, no.
Like a joint while I got
joint a day. I'm like, yeah,
I would think that you were like
just getting stoned all day.
I get stoned all day when I
don't have shit to do. Got You.
But if I have too much shit
to I get stoned all day.
That shit doesn't get done.
Oh you said you like blitz.
Yeah.
White light blues cause the little tobacco
gives you like this little extra high.
Yep. I'm glad you admitted it. Yeah. No
people who smoked blessed, they don't,
some of them they don't know that their
tobacco inc and they try to mask it and
say no,
you know it's a leaf and it's like no bro.
You like tobacco is tobacco with
weed? Yep. It's all like a combo high.
It cuts it a little bit too.
I like it before I go on stage.
That's my favorite before I go on stage.
That's certainly a little pickup but a
little bit high but a little like, Yay,
I'm happy how legal weed is these
days because it's like I would, I,
my son had a spring concert yesterday and
I would feel like shit back in the day
walking in there smelling like bud had,
cause he goes to the private school,
let me know this reflection
on him. Yeah. So it's like,
you know you got the weed head dad,
Blah Blah Blah and other things.
But it's like nowadays I should just cool
like no one cares. Nobody gives a fuck.
I've seen it happen cause I have a 22
year old daughter but then I also have an
11 and a nine year old and with the 22
year old when she was growing up it was
all weird. It was weird. It was like you
were a loser for smoking weed lay dates.
You know what I'm saying?
People coming over your house.
You got weed at the house.
Yeah Bro. Parents get weird.
I live like right up the
street from the school.
So like I'm getting real technical
with it. Like I'm in a school zone.
You know what I'm saying?
Like legitimately like I
could be not here right now.
Incarcerated for real lady. They locked
up today in Dallas. Did you see that shit?
Nah, no. I See lady a grandmother. They
locked her up cause she had CBD on her.
Yeah, she was a Dallas airport
outside even psychoactive.
And I think she had the oil like
first skin. Right. [inaudible] hey,
it's just ridiculous.
She's a old lady,
old lady who needs it
for arthritis as trading.
My wife's mom uses it for arthritis. It's
great. So older folks, Shit, my, uh, my,
I started to call her my ex baby's mom.
She's still my baby's mom,
but she has another baby on the
way in or a new relationship.
But she's able to take a CBD during
her pregnancy to help her, uh,
her nausea and all of that stuff. I was
like, why would you hate on CBD Bro? No,
it's amazing. It's the shit. It's,
my friend's son had some seizures.
He has like some sort of an epileptic
seizure, gives them CBD. It's gone.
He said every day he doesn't have them
anymore. That's amazing. I love that.
It's incredible. It's so good. It's
almost, you feel like you're lying, right.
Does so many different things that when
you talk about weed you feel like you're
lying. Yeah. I mean like these
days, in this day and age,
I was just telling somebody the other day,
smoking pot is going to be old school.
Like, you know what I mean?
We're still going to do it,
but it's totally moving
towards just ingesting it,
rubbing it on and all that shit sprays
so people just scared of it and it works.
Yeah. Like fuck. Like, you know what I
mean? The thing about the animals though,
it puts you in a weird place if
you get too much. Yeah. Yeah.
I've seen some people melt down.
Edibles are crazy.
So I got a homie who just took a THC
pill yesterday and he was talking about
types of Shit. Like that shit knocked
him out. He's probably still asleep,
but yeah, the edibles fuck you up.
You do edibles. Yeah, I do. But yeah,
I've had some bad experiences
like someone, not bad but like,
like completely lost touch with this
dimension. Damn. You know what I'm saying?
Like I had a friend who may THC pills.
Yep.
And I was taking him at a party once and
it was a party for a Jujitsu tournament.
So cause there was a Jujitsu tournament
and then there was this party afterwards
and by the time the pills would kick in,
I have no idea how much it was in there
cause he was like some handmade shit
that this guy put together himself.
A little capsules that you buy.
It was as high as I've ever been in my
life to the point where I wasn't even
seeing people.
I was seeing like a two dimensional cut
out of the person and behind them I was
seeing like their true intentions
are so like a really high fuck.
And I was talking to this
one dude and he was just,
he was a high level Jujitsu
guy was who was a really odd,
it was a very strange feeling.
I got talking to this cat then I'm like
a month later he was on the run for
rape. Yeah. He uh,
raped some woman and then he escaped
and then he was so addicted to Jujitsu.
The story was that he started
training again with a fake name,
but he was like this high level black
belt. And there's only that this,
especially back then when this happens,
it's like the early two thousands,
there's only a certain number of high
level black belts that are running around.
Right.
So he put on this fake Brazilian name
and started training and like the Pacific
northwest, but he's strangling black belts
and everybody's like, what the fuck is,
who is this guy? So people ask, hey,
someone took a picture of
him and I go with that. Guys
want it for right. Oh Shit.
But I remember talking to him on
these THC pills being like, like some,
there's some wiring that's not correct.
Oh fuck yeah.
Damn dog. That's an whoa. Yeah.
THC pills. They expose things they
do, Bro. I did mushrooms in it.
Exposed there yet. Do you
do shrimps? Yeah, yeah, Yup.
I fuck with mushrooms because that's
what happened with me when I was on
mushrooms.
I was able to see people's true intentions
because being a rapper and shit like
that, you know, you'd be
having to peel back the layers,
layers and layers and layers and I
was trying to peel my own layers back.
It just for my own shore personal
every way I ended up. Yeah. Yup.
And I ended up being like backstage
somewhere and I was like fuck. I was like,
I'm around all these people and like
I really see the true intentions.
Then there was like,
I see what crowd they are and it was like,
I felt like I was separated,
you know what I mean?
I mean it was like I was on a boat all
the way out here and they were on the,
on a all on an island party and
then I was like, damn, yeah,
I can see what's going on over there.
But it was cool.
Like I do mushrooms every now and then.
I don't fuck with it all the time.
I haven't done them in like three years
because they help you see shit like that.
So it's like for me, I'll
take that experience and
I'll just live with it. Yeah.
I don't need to keep going
through it over and over.
Like you've probably seen that
dude and was like, oh shit.
Now I know people who are rapey.
As soon as I see him,
I knew he was dangerous. Like he
was a legitimately dangerous person.
Like not just saying Bro, not just to
train killer, but he was dangerous.
Like the way he thought about things.
Oh,
that's why there's people like that
out there. Yeah. Yeah. You, you, you,
you don't know until you experience it.
And that was a mild experience compared
to most people's counters to psychos out
there. Fucking crazy
motherfuckers bro. I know, I know.
Just probably in fighting too.
That's why I feel like more people need
to like smoke weed and a and train.
I think so too because it balances.
Training's great man.
He alleviates all that
shit with most people.
But there's going to be some dude's
just like that guy that are just,
they're just out there. It's taken it
to that level, like, yeah, yeah. Yup.
That's crazy. When you think about the
world of fighting and competition, I mean,
you're dealing with people that are
taking the biggest risks. They don't,
they don't have to do that. Right. This is
like a choice. Right. They can get a job.
The choices.
I want to get a job trying to fuck up
other people who have a job trying to fuck
up people. The killers, the
trained killers is going after
each other. Right, right.
And when you're around those dudes,
one of the things you want,
one of the things you realize
very early on you have,
you can have your preconceived
notions about them being like, Meh.
Like mean people are violent people.
They're people of character. Yes, sir.
You have to have extreme character
to pull off what they do. Yeah. Yup.
There's some of the best people I've ever
met in my life are fighters. Yep. Yep.
They, they're, they're a
different breed of human being.
Yeah. They chose that path.
They chose it, knows no one's
forcing them or not in more. Right.
They decide to go and do that. And that's
why it's so exciting to watch. Right,
right. Cause you know that they're
putting everything on the line. Right.
I look at it like, like
you said, they chose that.
So to become an athlete to, to choose
to fight, you know what I mean?
Like, and a lot of them are
really, like you said, smart,
they're technical and especially how the
sport is developing these days because
people don't want the longterm damage,
but they want to still like,
you know what I mean?
Go hard.
So they're coming up with fucking
all types of ways to do this shit.
And it's like,
at the end of the day,
you have to be creative or you have to
have some type of something up here.
You know what I mean? You're
not just fighting to be
fighting, you know? So yeah,
I think they all go in and for the
same reason, they're all there.
They're trying to find out if they can
do it right and the beginning get up and
they have a just a drive to prove
that they're the best. Right.
I was just talking to somebody
the other day about that. Um,
it was like a crazy argument because
they were saying how fight fans are just
there for knockouts and I was like, you
definitely have your, your knockout fans.
It's was like, those are probably
the people who pay the most.
You know what I mean?
It's like, but I was like,
you got to give credit to a lot of people
who understand fighting and love it
and are viewing it for that aspect.
It's like, yeah, you know, when you,
you watch football, like a lot of
people played football and you know,
wished they could have been that
person on the field. They just haven't,
you know what I mean? So I was
trying to explain to him, I was like,
it was a huge crowd of people who
actually know about this shit and who are
knowledgeable in those people support it
as well. It was weird. Yeah. I feel you.
I know exactly what you're saying.
There's some people that just want to
see people get beat up and some people
didn't want to see Floyd Mayweather
duck punches. Right. You know,
one of the best things about
Floyd Mayweather and Canelo
wasn't that Floyd beat
Canelo up. He out boxed him. Right.
But he showed this level of defense.
If you're a boxing fan, you're like
Jesus Christ. Like he knows everything.
That's comment.
Yep.
He's always in the right angle is always
one step ahead and that's why he's so
good. His defenses Floyd's
only been hit like a few times.
His whole career. Really hard. See
like Shane hit him a couple times. Uh,
was it my Donna,
Donna hit him really hard one and they
fucking like save the clip and play it
over and over. Just cause
like so he can be hit. Yeah.
Really think about other boxers, how much
they get hit and compared to the flu.
I love watching that. I love watching
someone who could move like that.
My favorite fighter to watch the
UFC was mighty mouse. [inaudible]
not just because he was the best
pound for pound fighter on the planet,
but because he was not getting hit right.
He was occasionally someone would tell
like John May org attacked him on the
straight leg.
Occasionally some guys hit him,
but most times things are just grazing.
Yeah. Things are getting blocked. Right.
Even if he gets hit, he's
moving. He's a puzzle. Right?
Like if you're a fan of martial arts,
you want to see the master of the puzzle.
Exactly. Hell yeah. And I don't,
I don't count them people out and I
wouldn't fucking sit in front of the dude
and let him just be like,
oh yeah, everybody will see
knockouts like, Nah Bro.
Like it's not like that fail. I think
everybody likes both things though.
It's like when you get like
Arturo Gotti versus Micky Ward,
did you ever see that fight?
Uh, I will have to track.
It was a trilogy of fucking wars
between these two guys that weren't not
champion.
They were,
they were like one step below at
the time of their career being like
championship level. So they weren't like
in threat of fighting for the title.
No one talked through like Floyd was
better than both of them by far. Right.
But what they were doing was showing
the two guys that are similarly talented
can put on like the most entertaining
fight in the world. It was incredible.
It's crazy to watch it back
and forth, back forth. I
like watching that too. Yeah.
Yup. You know? Yeah. I want to
see a good fight. Me Personally,
I like watching both things.
I like watching someone
just completely Willie pep,
somebody just like pronounced Whitaker
used to do. Yeah. Yup. He's a great boxer.
He couldn't hit him. Nope.
He was so slick. Nope.
You know when you can only do that for
so long, like in any sport, you know,
it'd be at the top for so long.
Watch those performances when
those guys were at the top,
that shows you what's possible.
Hell yeah.
And it's just good to see somebody
like master their craft to, yeah.
Cause you see him come up like you watch
him be I and then it's like they become
the shit and it's like, oh yeah,
that, you know what I mean?
I seen this dude like start from just
being okay and now he's just fucking shit
up. You see them learn and you see them
develop and all of that stuff is fun.
Like you grow with them.
That's a good combination of
getting to the bottom of shit.
His weed and martial arts, that's
a good combination. 100% really is,
I do like a lot of my thinking is just
from like after I train I just sit there
and just think about nothing.
But you know what I mean?
Ideas come to me how to deal with
situations, you know what I mean?
Because it just, I don't know. It just
happens like that just flows. Yeah. Yeah.
It flows
and I think like the training helps
you get all the bullshit off your back,
right? Hell yeah. Right. Yeah.
Yup. Especially for me too,
cause like I party a lot and I'm
in the studio till like five,
six in the morning.
I'm drinking and stuff like that.
So to just be going down that path and
doing that every day, bro, I look crazy.
I'll feel crazy. Like I have to
get that off of me, like out of me.
You know what I mean? Yeah.
That's why your gym is crazy.
But I need to do something like that for
myself. It's nice to have at some point.
Like that's how I look
at you like the old g.
So it's like I'm not going to
go do it tomorrow. Like, hey,
everybody built me a gym. But you
know, eventually that's the goal.
When I look back, I'll be like, I seen
Joe's gym in us. That's what made dude,
you train hard. I've seen your
videos. Yeah. I get to work.
You work at an unbreakable, your
spot. That's a great gym. Yeah.
It's a really good gym. Uh, Jay
Glazer. Yeah. He owns that spot. Very,
very impressive place. He put together
an awesome place. Yeah. Yeah. It's cool.
The team there is good. Um, like I said,
it's not all about like just fighting and
being, you know, the biggest, baddest,
meanest motherfucker.
Like they really taught me about my body.
That's what they do. They teach you there,
whatever your goals are, they bring you,
you know, up to that
speed. So it was like,
I weighed like 140 pounds ever since I
got out of high school and I was like,
fuck,
I gotta get some ways.
They helped me out and does it snoop
train there too. This is video.
Snoop sparring. He's fine. Daniel
Seraphim. Daniel's fucking crazy.
Yeah, I know that guy. He was
fights before. He said tank.
He is crazy. You like guys a
tank. Nuts. His thing is like, Yo,
I gotta get hit. I'm
like, all right Daniel.
You know he's got to get
him to wake himself up. Wow.
There is those hits and his barn with
them. Yeah. The soup was going at it.
So he's trying to take him out.
Dude.
Snoop throw some good shots of them
right there. Yeah. Snoop skills.
He really does. I'm glad Daniel
Duck that one. Yeah. I mean,
let him smoke. I guarantee you snoop
Dogg. That's funny right there.
A lot of people in the regular
fist fight. Yeah, he's tall.
His Shit to look at him and at him
like that. Look at those arms. Yeah,
bit. Ugh. Ah, you can
look pat. Go ahead snoop.
So that was ah,
that Seraphin kinds of tank.
Yeah. He fought in UFC for awhile. They're
still fighting. Still active. Yeah.
I think he's in Brazil
right now. Yeah. Yup.
He was working at the gym for
a minute. Then he, I guess
he chilled out. Yeah. It's,
anyway, my point was the videos. It's
nice to see because you're training hard,
like watching you do more time.
Get the pads.
You're really putting in work on this,
sir. Yeah. Yeah. It's a everyday thing.
It's a journey. Like, you know what I
mean? I'm just trying to learn. Ernie.
Ernie Reyes is my, uh, oh shit I sent
you. I right there. That was fun.
He was teaching me some stuff.
Why was early though? I suck
right there. It's still though.
Do you are sparring right there with
one of the greatest Muay Thai fighters,
if not the greatest of all time. Yeah.
Dues. Super tiny. He's amazing. Yeah,
he's really good. His videos
like highlights. You ever
see that jumping left?
Switch kick. He knocked that dude out with
yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Outstanding.
Crazy kick. So how cool is that man, you,
you're sparring with one of the
greatest of all time. It's fun as fuck.
Cause it's like those people like, you
know about fighters, they're the majority.
Like you said when you meet them
they, they're cool as hell. Yeah.
So to meet him and him not wanting to
whoop my ass or like tell me like, hey,
you look goofy.
Sit down.
He's like showing me shit that I could
use later. So it was like, it was cool.
Well the Thais have a really interesting
way of sparring. Some of them do,
they play right.
They don't hit each other full blast.
They're like tap and they'd
laugh around and joke around.
They're just developing their timing
cause they fight so often. Yep.
John Wayne Pars,
a friend of mine from Australia,
multiple time world champion
and he, you know, he would, uh,
talk in depth about how they would play.
They just play. They just hit each other.
Just slap each other a little bit and
then you like that way they get understand
the timing of it,
but they never worry about it and they
don't get hurt and they can do it all the
time.
It's a really smart way to do it.
But you'll see guys like Seraphina and
he's capable of doing that so he could
spar with a guy like snoop
or it got like sand track.
It's barley with the guy like
you and just play with you.
Everybody just have a good time and it's
fun at the end. Yep. Super Fun. Yeah. Yup,
Yup. Hell yeah. Definitely
seen that a lot.
Like on Instagram and even with my
trainers, we'll do it like mid, early.
We was just doing that yesterday where
it's like developing the timing of the
kicks where it's like, you kicked me,
I kick you, I can't you, you kick me,
I kicked you twice, you kicked me three
times. I kick you was like you said,
just play it around. Yeah. And like
when you got a good sparring partner,
you can take care of each other.
Exactly. Don't hurt each other.
There's no ego involved and
the ties they do like knees,
they'll, they'll need the fuck out of each
other. Like it looks like kind of hard,
but they're just making
their bodies harder like you
said for later because it's
like they're used to it.
A lot of times they'll slap each other
with the side of their leg to write in
and really drive the knee
and you'll just hear yeah,
they're just slapping
each other a little bit.
But it's obviously it's very effective.
Like they figured something out.
You got some crazy kicks.
Thank you. Yeah, I seen uh,
what was it a sidekick that you did?
Probably turning sidekick. Yeah.
You gotta teach me then I'll
teach you that. Yeah, I want that.
I just need the form because I'm learning
just a regular psyche like a slide,
you know what I mean?
Go to like a taekwondo school.
They'd be the best at showing you how
to do. I'll definitely show you how,
but if you need a place to train,
find like a really good taekwondo school.
Cause one thing talk window has some
things that you know won't work in MMA.
If you're adding take downs
and punches to the face,
but because they don't punch to the face
and tournaments you get used to doing
crazy, cacs crazier. They have a lot of
weird, a lot of weird leg dexterity stuff.
And if you get good at that stuff,
I think that's a good,
I had a kid that wanted to fight,
I would say let's just do some kill
cushion or some taekwondo first.
Just do some karate. Something where you
develop in leg dexterity. Paleo, Dan,
as you get a little older than
move you into Moitai. Right.
So you could do both things because if
someone's caught you when guys are like
constantly chopping at the legs,
they never really developed the kind of
spinning kicks that you guys do where
they don't kick the legs.
Those are the guys that developed the
best spinning kicks cause it's so easy to
chop the legs and effective
the chop the legs out.
So a lot of those techniques don't really
get that dialed in to the level that
they get dialed in from a taekwondo guy
cause they can't kick each other in the
legs. Right, right, right, right.
It's kind of a dumb way to fight
cause you should kick the legs,
but at the end of the day it,
it allowed them to develop some crazy
shit and a lot of weird spinning stuff
spilling.
Know
some of those guys are so fast
and the powers insane. Yeah, yeah.
Cause just all momentum in torque
and book crazy shit. But it's just,
it's hard to develop,
right?
It's hard to develop those texts like
a lot of posture and you gotta really,
you gotta be balanced and you
got that knee is everything.
You gotta that Shit how you aim it.
So it's like when you're spinning or
even if you're just standing there,
you have to have correct posture and
to be able to do a couple of kicks.
Like you said,
it's like a lot going sh
coming at somebody spending
blitz and doing all types
of Shit.
So it's different for show,
it's really good for your balance to
do that as a young kid than learn some
other shit later. Right.
You'll have balance. Yeah.
That's what I've seen when you kicked
the fuck out of that show was like
yellowish, like really balanced and
straight. Like, you know what I mean? The,
the tech, cause a lot of people
you might be strong as fuck,
but you could see technique. Right, right,
right. You know what I mean? And this,
if you do the shit over and over
and over and really perfected,
that's different than just
being able to throw a strong
cake. Yeah. Maybe. Yeah. Um,
techniques, everything man that
way in Jujitsu so that way.
And it's gotta be that way in music.
It's going to be that way in everything.
Yeah, definitely. Man. I'm in a
studio like all the time practicing,
like I could write a song
before this interview's over,
but that's because I practice,
you know,
it's not because like I'm the
most lyrical person in the world.
It's like I just fucking rap every
day. Like, you know what I mean?
So it should come easy.
So when you write,
do you write things out or do you,
do you do it out in your head? Like,
I know Jay z supposedly
doesn't write anything. Right.
It just keeps it all in his head,
which is incredible.
It's awesome that he can do
that. Right? It's kind of
insane. Yeah. Yeah. Yup. I have,
I have different processes. So like
for me, I kind of, I've melodies,
like I'll sing and I'll wrap.
So it's a lot easier for me to just
have a melody in my head and make
up the words as I go.
But if I'm writing lyrics,
like writing words down
where I actually wrap it,
that's when I'm going to use the paper,
you know?
But there's different ways
to do it because I honestly,
this is what my studio set up looks like.
It's like a chair.
The Mike is right here.
I don't go in the booth for anything
in my engineer's sitting right there.
So it's like we're, we're
coming up with it as, as we go.
Like I'll take a little break, just write
something down and then I just jumped,
jumped straight back on it.
You know what I mean?
So there's different techniques though.
Cause a lot of the Times
sometimes I won't write shit.
I'll just go and just make it up
and just keep going, keep flowing.
Or there's times where I could just lay
a melody and then write the words to it
later. So it's just different,
you know, ways to approach it.
So you just do it based on
however you feel that day,
whatever to track really calls for.
It's like if,
if the song is something that I get
instinct inspiration, I'm like, oh,
I'm a knock it out right now.
Or if some that I want to
live with for a little bit,
I'll just do as much as I'm happy with
at that point and then move on to the
next thing, come back to it later and
just make sure everything is fresh.
I like to keep everything fresh,
keep it fun, keep it loose.
And I don't really overthink anything.
If it's not there, then I just go,
go away from it and find something
that's more fun. Hell yeah,
that's a, it's a beautiful freedom
to be able to do that. You know,
obviously pick the right fucking job.
I swear like, you know, it's,
it's, uh, it's work because I,
I'm always looking for what's next.
You know what I mean? For the fans,
for the listeners, for the people who
supported me all the way to this point,
right. Like, okay, I got to push
myself, I've got to do what's next.
I gotta it's gotta be crazy. You know
what I mean? I've got a son, he's sick.
So I was like,
I got to impress him.
I couldn't have him just listening to a
whole bunch of other rappers and not my
music. So I was like, yeah.
Yeah. It's uh, you know,
it is an interesting responsibility
you have, right? Yeah. Yeah.
And a guy like you becomes
famous to interesting.
Like you have so many people that want,
you know,
and I think we need to call it a
different thing other than work. Yeah.
Cause it's like there's work, like,
fuck, I work for ups. Yeah. That's cool.
They've got good benefits,
but that's work. Right. But
what you're doing is like,
you love it. Yeah. Hell yeah. You know,
when you love something and almost we
needed better word. Yeah. For sure.
It's the same word as working at
Mcdonald's. The same word work,
work. Uh, mark. The word would
be you need a better word,
like a passion project and able to
do what you want to do. Exactly.
Whatever that thing is. Yeah. Yup. No, I
believe that that's, that's a good point.
Cause it's not the same work.
That's not the same thing. No,
it's not the same thing we needed. We've
done a work put in the work. Yeah. Yeah.
That's why we had shit
job at, in your life. You know what that
is? That's work. Yeah. We put in the work.
We've done that,
but saying I'm going to work.
When you go on to do something you
love, you're excited about. Yeah. It's,
we need a better word. Yeah.
That's why I think. No, it's true.
That's why people get pissed at me.
They're not going to work.
It is a hundred girls there.
[inaudible]
Bro.
I had to punch in just like you.
Yeah. And that sense, the world
is just not fair. You know,
some people's jobs are not the same.
Yeah.
I mean fuck you stop and think about
how fortunate you are. Yeah, Yup.
Yeah. I thank God every day, Bro.
Beautiful all the time. Cause it is,
it is a blessing.
I'm literally like last night I'm like
right in a song and the only problem that
I had was like a girls as was right on me
and I was like, baby, like I, I'm
enjoying this as much as you are,
but I gotta like physically,
right.
So it's like your ass is like moving
my arm around. Like you can do that,
but just right there,
you know what I mean?
Like I know and I started thinking
about it, I was like, wow,
these are my problems.
Like yeah, that's cool.
Just snapped a little bit of discipline.
I'm cool with that.
That's amazing. Well, I'm cool with that
for sure. That's amazing. Yeah. Yup.
And the song got written so
we beautiful job got done.
Yeah. That's it. There's another word,
right? [inaudible] you were off work here.
You're working, obviously you've been
working at it, but it needs a better word,
a nobler word. The fans will come
up with the word for shorter.
They're way more creative. You've got
way more time on their hands. Yeah,
I think they will figure it out and
we'll report back for show. Find it.
I did just make sense. There's no way.
It's the same thing. It can't be, Nah,
hell Nah for show. Nope. Yeah,
and that's why I was telling people when
people always try to think down there
was trying to think, man, that's easy for
you to say or not everybody can make it.
Yeah, you're right. Not Everybody can
truth, but maybe you can write like,
what do you, what does that mean?
Not Everybody can. Everybody can.
Everybody's going to do everything that
everybody's going to walk to the top of
the hill. That's the thing. Some
people are gonna stop halfway and go,
I can't do things. That's the thing.
People limit themselves in a crazy way.
They're like, oh yeah, everybody can't
do it. It's like you said, it's like, no,
everybody can't do it. It takes
a lot. You know what I mean?
You gotta fucking go through the Shit
to get it. But when you get there,
it looks awesome. Right? So yeah.
I mean fuck, it's whatever it is.
Try to figure it out and go
do it. Hell yeah. Hell yeah.
Like you said at the top of the hill,
it looks great,
but some people settle for the middle.
Yeah.
And they get mad if people get to
the top. This motherfucker, you know,
they get mad. Yeah. Yup. At the top, man,
there's no one who's like you.
It doesn't work hard. Right.
So that's the myth, right? That's the
thing too. It's like, man, it's a, again,
the wrong word for it, right.
Passion, hard, whatever it is. I mean,
you dedicated to your craft
and maintaining it is,
there's an art to that, right?
Because you work so freaking
hard to get to where you're at.
And then you get there and it's like, oh
fuck, what do I do? Like there's no rest.
There's no rest.
And everything that was acceptable
before becomes unacceptable because now
you're up here. Uh, you know what I
mean? So it's like, yeah, you have to,
you have to, you have to pick your shots
and like, you know what I'm saying?
Can't really like, just go crazy
like you did back in the day.
So there's a art to it,
you know what I mean?
And that's how you really maintain and
stay in that spot and even level up.
So do you consciously think,
okay,
a balance out enjoyment with things
that I have to do to stay disciplined?
100% yeah, 100% that's a very smart
way of looking at it. Yeah. Yup.
100% like those,
there has to be a balance of each
because it's like, all right,
now I'm at this new level.
Like whether I want to behave like
this or not. I put myself here,
I worked hard, now I'm with these
elite motherfuckers. So this is the,
this is how I have to act because
I'm not down here anymore.
I worked from here to get here.
So what happens? You balanced,
you put things into place,
you do a little bit of this little
bit of that instead of a lot of that,
you know what I mean?
And you just pick your shots and it's
like you're going to get everything in the
end. This is how it's just
planning how it's supposed to be,
but you just piece it together
just a little bit differently.
Like I just turned 31 walk down.
I'm about to be 32 as young too.
A lot of people that's old
to some people as well,
but for me it's like there's a whole
new mind state, you know what I mean?
And I feel like through my twenties I
was actually like a fucking teenager and
like now I'm an adult. So now I look
at things a little bit differently.
It's like, Yo, I was really a kid.
This is how you behave as an
adult for the rest of your life.
And it still involves a whole
bunch of partying and having fun,
but the business gets handled and things
get approached totally differently.
That's a balanced way of looking
at it. Man, I love it. Enjoy it.
That's how they think too.
Like people have to understand too,
to be someone like you,
to be a very successful rapper and to
not expect you to live the way you talk
about all the time. It's so
ridiculous. Right, right, right, right.
Like you don't think he wants to party.
He's talking about partying all the time.
I think he wants to party [inaudible]
party. This is just an act. Yeah. Yeah.
It's weird. Right? It's
crazy as fuck because people,
they want you to be you. They want me
to be myself. Right. They want to party.
They didn't want
to take shots. They want to smoke weed.
They want to stay up all night. Yeah.
Why is that bad?
It's not so many people want to do it,
but it gives us a image in some
people's minds like frivolous life.
[inaudible] frivolous thinking,
partying [inaudible] what are you doing?
Drinking and smoking.
What are you enjoying yourself?
And then they come around and do
the same thing cause they want it.
It's like I have like a weird place in
life where I think I'm like the key to a
lot of shit because it's like
if you want to enjoy yourself,
I'm a guy. You know what
I mean? It's like, aw man,
I'm just fucking going to live
through wisdom. It shows up.
He's going to light the joint.
It's going to be amazing if you
want to fucking be professional,
like especially in what I do,
because there's a whole lot of
rappers who like aren't business,
you know what I mean?
They're not thinking like that.
So for those guys, I'm
their guy. Like they're,
they look at me like where's
has his shit together?
Like he really handles his
business. He talks to people,
he shows up, he does this,
he does that. So to be the
party guy and the business guy,
it's like amazing. You
know what I mean? It's a,
it's a lane that I kind of car for myself,
but it's me in real life.
So it's like,
that's the only thing I have to do
is really just completely be myself.
Just be 100 fucking show up. Do
my business thing. Tell people,
do the right thing and fucking
light to join. You know what I mean?
That's it. That's a crazy business, sir.
I'm, I'm good. I'm straight like that.
That's amazing. Yeah. Yup. People
listening to this support like wow,
he could beat yourself for a living,
for a show, bro. This blessing.
It's a blessing. I, John
Witherspoon on yesterday, but
the son, j d okay. You know,
pops with a spoon. Yeah. Yup.
And that's basically what he is.
He's one of the funniest fucking human
beings that's ever lived and just keep a
camera on them.
Just keep a camera on him.
That falls the guy from mass phase
it in real life. Oh, he's amazing.
He's so funny. He's, he's legit.
My face was hurting today.
Like the cheekbone muscles.
They're like, ah, hey.
He probably got some crazy ass stories.
Oh yeah.
That motherfucker been in the game
forever and he's, that's who he is.
He got paid to be who he is. Figuring out
how to just be who he is all the time.
Yup. It's the same damn bro. Yeah. Yeah.
It's not limited to a one
or two of us right now.
There's a bunch of different paths.
That's the Copart. Yeah. Nope. Yup.
Hell yeah. So how many years you've
been trained in martial arts now? Uh,
this is my second year. Wow. Only two
years. That's amazing. Again, what?
35 pounds. He'll pull up a video of
him hitting pads. That's incredible.
Is it? Cause I don't know.
Tell him, tell him what,
what video is probably going to be old.
But it's all good though.
You know how we are. You can hit hard.
You have good technique. You turn,
you turn your hips and shoulders in
the bay. Yeah. Yup. You do it right.
So it's very that it's only two
years in. Yo, I'm learning
that. Yeah. I love it.
I love it when people take a chance to
try something new. Yeah, that's old.
But you know, we'll get there. So
how many months had you been in here?
Like you say, this is old.
This was probably like a
year. A year ago? Yeah. Yep.
Still seriously though. Good technique
for someone who's been doing it a year.
The way you're moving. I mean,
there's no fat to your movements.
See what I'm saying?
Like everything you're doing,
it might not be the fastest in the
world are the most devastating,
but you're doing it perfect.
Thank you.
Doing exactly how you're
supposed to do it.
And then you just get better and
better from there. There you go.
We're talking about is the
change in your physique,
but mean you became fucking treaded.
It's oppressive. Yeah. Thank you.
That's only through hard work. You
can't do it any other way. Yeah, just,
just work and eat. And I was
all, oh, I'm sorry. That's mine.
That's hard to cut that off. Sorry
about that guys. That's no worries man.
Welcome to the wonderful world of
convenience. There we go. Bam. Um, yeah.
Eating like a motherfucker, bro. I, yeah,
I had to like force myself to eat, um,
to gain weight, to gain weight. I'm
fucking just moving around so much.
I already have a quick metabolism,
so then you add working out to that.
So it's like I'm burning so much old
setting alarms to eat really little. Yeah.
Yup.
Getting a little bit more arrest.
Too many alarms he eat
like how's that work there?
Like wake up and then you eat and then
go to sleep, eat, go back to sleep train.
He kind of to
by Jesus Christ.
I do a lot of like,
like ginger shots.
I'm like shit like that to help like yeah,
to read all of that shit too. Cause like
you said that fuck your stomach up. Why?
Who told you to get up in the middle of
the night? Neat though. My trainer. Yeah.
Yeah. Yup. I would, uh,
I would say that your sleep cycles more
important than anything. It wasn't,
it's not like breaking my sleep.
It's like more like yo eat.
Oh you mean like you set an alarm
like while you're awake? Yeah. Oh,
can I see what you're saying?
I've never heard anybody telling someone
to wake up in the middle of the night
and eat. Nah, not like to
hear that. That's why it was
weird. I heard that from a,
there was that movie with Clint Eastwood
where he played a boxing trainer and
his daughter, that famous
actress play the boxer. Man,
that billion dollar baby or toddler.
Yeah.
Yeah. When that actress, what
is her name? Hillary Swank.
Hilary Swank. The job. Hillary. Thank
you. We can change on the ball job man.
When she was training for that,
I think that's what I read,
that they had an alarm set but she would
wake up in the middle of the night and
have a protein shake. Oh really?
And then go back to sleep again.
Now I'm not doing that. Okay
now. No, no breaking asleep. Uh,
just regular eating habits just
reminded myself, you know what I mean?
Cause I was eating like
twice a day on some,
just some rock star Shit.
Can't live like that, bro.
That shit is wack. Do you
have a nutritionist or someone
who handles your meals?
Meal preps. Yeah. You got that.
Because I don't cook. Right.
So it's like they just deliver
my meals. That's nice. Yeah. Yup.
It's really nice actually.
Yeah.
Cause I'm single so it's like I don't
really got nobody in the house like
cooking or making all
that shit happen for me.
So it just comes through the door so
you can make sure everything's healthy.
Exactly what you want all that up for you.
It's fresh every couple of days.
That's a good thing to not
have to think about the food.
The food is like a big part of
it and working out as one thing.
People just want to get big.
Like you said. I'm a, well
like we were talking about,
it's like mind, body and soul.
Right. So the food is further, so
keep that fucking meet alive yet. Keep
the body moving. Yep. Are you, uh,
do you ever do yoga or anything like
that? I would. You would? Yeah. Yep.
I need a yoga instructor.
Who's the best yoga is,
I don't know man. You do yoga?
Yeah, I love it. Yeah. Yup.
How long do, how long you,
oh yeah, I see. You do like some hot
yoga and shit. Yeah, man. Yup. Yeah,
she's intense, right? It's
kind of intense. Yeah. But it's
a, it's great for you, man.
Just stretches you out. Loosens
you up. That's what I need to do.
I need to stretch, you know? Yeah,
I do like regular normal stretching,
but some yoga would be hot.
Yeah,
it's good too because because
of the heat in the room,
everything gets real loose.
Yeah.
You can really kind of dig into like
certain things stressed your frack to test
your flexibility to stretch things
out a little bit more. Gotcha.
Just keeps you pliable.
Gotcha.
You know when you're doing a lot of hard
things like Moy Thai or weightlifting,
everything's hard.
Like there's not,
not enough stretching things out and
totally maintaining your range of motion.
Yeah. Especially as you get
older, how often you do it.
I tried to do it at least once a week,
but I often fail,
but a two times a week in a good
week. Okay. Yeah. It's all mixed. It,
I can't do one thing every day board,
so in order to stay active I just have
to do a bunch of different things.
That make sense.
It's whether it's martial arts
running or lifting or whatever it is.
I feel like through time you like
added those things in, right? Yeah.
It was just like, all right,
I'm going to do this. Yeah.
The hill down into the most recent thing.
Okay, cool. So what's hill running?
Cause I take my dog running through these
steep ass fucking hills and then you
know, sprinting up these, it's
the most ruthless workout. Right.
And you know if you've ever
run hills. Yes. Yeah. Yes.
The worst sand dunes. I don't
like it. Sand dunes are the worst.
That's probably sucks. It sucks. You have
never get up there. He just, he keep,
you keep pushing and you're pushing
sand and pushing Sam. There's no hard,
you don't ever bounce off anything,
right. You just pushing through soft shit.
It's, you're trying to
find like balance and yeah.
That's some real martial arts shit though.
Yeah, for sure. That's a mental shift.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You're learning about yourself and
you're running up a fucking sand dune.
You're mastering a fucking moving thing.
Things Melton the whole time
you're trying. Yeah. Wow. Okay.
And you're forcing your brain, your body
to do what your mind wants it to listen,
bitch. I know you don't want to do this.
You're going to do this. That's like a,
I heard the Diaz brothers do some
crazy shit like swimming. Oh yeah,
they do triathlons. Yeah.
Fuck that Nick Diaz.
I think it's now five times that he
swam back from Alcatraz. Fuck that.
Yeah. I'll contrast man. Sharks.
Sharks. That, that's why I'm with you.
Fuck that. That's so crazy.
Those guys are so crazy.
That's like you and the sand
dunes though. Well, I haven't do,
I don't do sand dunes. Oh, if I had one
near me, I would do it. I run hills,
which is definitely easier than sand
dunes, but it's still hard as fuck. Good.
Steep ass hill. It's the best for
transit grass. Yeah. Dirt, dirt,
rocks. Just anything.
Just as trails. Damn, Bro.
Yeah. I'm gonna get there someday.
You'll see me come see me blazing.
I'll take you out. We'll go running
together. I like to hike. It's a,
it's a great workout, man. And the thing
about it is it amps everything else out.
Yeah. So like, um, it makes your
kicking stronger. There's more wind.
It just accentuates your ability to
explode because you're running hills,
so you're always going up.
It's like you're doing these crazy
plyometrics and use develop this.
Does that forward a stronger power
in your legs and your lower trunk?
Boom. Yeah. More kitten power.
Yep. That makes sense. Yeah.
I feel like I will fuck with
it. Dude. You'd love it.
Cause I like to just tune
shit out and just go. Yeah.
So like the pain from running up the
hill would just, I would be like,
yes. Yeah. I'm not even gonna think about
this. Let me think about something else.
Yeah. Well, and you get a goal,
right? You set a goal like a mile,
put yourself at one mile who and then turn
around and go back for the other mile.
Woo. Yeah. And if he can, if he can
do that, I'm good. Steep ass hills.
When you're done, you feel like you
fought a battle with your brain. Woo.
It's like, you know, you didn't want to do
that, but you did didn't dog. All right.
That's nothing compared to like some
people do. Yeah. But Dot. That's, that's,
that sounds like, you know, something
that we could unlock later on in my life,
I think for everybody.
Doing something that's super strenuous
for all the time is important. Yeah.
For show for sure.
That's part of the reason
why I fuck with training,
you know so much. Cause it's not
easy and it it, it breaks you.
Yeah. But you reach points
where it's like, okay,
now I'm just cruising so
I need another challenge.
Like you're just sharpening the shit
after a certain point. So it's like,
all right, now I'm gonna go
run some sand dunes. Yeah.
Swim from Alcatraz. So yeah, I can get it.
There's doing somewhere down there like
Orange County or they're pretty famous.
10 run up Manhattan Beach Park.
That makes sense.
It's a park. Yeah. Yeah. I was just,
there's a video of Kevin Durant and
Russell Westbrook train in there.
I was about to pull up shit that we
want to see somebody run on those dunes.
Okay.
Last broke be doing it.
I know a lot of fighters do
it in Australia. I believe
Robert Whitaker does it.
Yeah. See I'm backwards. When
you do shit like this on Sam,
that is phenomenal for your blog
is so hard to do, man. Dying.
Dying.
That's so hard to do.
And I wonder if they're running with just
socks on. It looks like they are. Yeah.
That's amazing. Too difficult. Fuck man.
Cause that makes your feet
strong cause you just,
you've using every muscle in your
toes to push through that sand.
That's difficult. Fuck. There's
levels to this life. Yeah.
That's literally who's going to go to
the top or who's going to stop in the
middle? Yep. Yeah, yeah. Fuck those
little decisions you make every day.
I just seen my whole life
just running up some dude.
Yeah, that was cool. Yeah. That's awesome.
It's like a mental martial art to wow.
You're testing the mind hellion and
like getting stronger at the same time.
That's the cold part.
Yeah.
So it's like you could be up here the
whole time and you're building all of this
and becoming more explosive
and more dangerous.
The lighter on your feet and just when
you started training and seeing these
awesome benefits will you
like, God dammit. Why wasn't
I doing this all the time?
Um, I'm actually happy that I, that I
waited for a little bit cause I enjoy it.
It's not like, oh, to
me, you know what I mean?
It's not something that I'm
tired of or that that's a chore.
I'm still figuring out new shit like
all the time and getting better,
you know what I mean? And like, uh,
for me I feel like the
physical was probably like
the first thing to come to me,
uh, as like a, as a reward, as benefit.
Like I see the, the, the physical shit,
but now it's like the feeling that I
get, you know what I mean? Or like,
like we said,
like posture and balance and technique
improving and shit like that.
So it's like learning that and feeling
that and having that being a part of the
process,
I'm happy that now is,
is happening as opposed to it being
like old and played out to me.
That's interesting. I think you'd love
it either way. Yeah. I still love it.
I still love training and I've
been talking forever and forever.
I'm 51 I started training when I
was really seriously when I was 15.
Oh Shit. Damn. So what the
fuck was I doing? Yeah,
I was feeling, I was rapping.
We wrap it when you're 15 wow.
When did you first get into student?
That's one thing I really admire about
a lot of rappers because we're always
working.
Rappers are always in the studio.
Hopefully that's like a big thing though.
It's like there's a discipline
aspect to it then I don't think that
gets appreciated. Yeah, you have to be,
you're always in the lab.
They always working on constantly.
It's like training and you gotta be, you
gotta work at it. It's competitive. Yeah.
Yeah. You gotta be in a
studio, work with producers.
You got to becoming new fucking no one
who's next and who's like working with
them and shit like that. So
like at the end of the day,
yeah, it's a crap. The Shit.
I've been in the studio since I was like
1415 and there was times where my dad
used to have to tell me like,
Yo, get out of the studio.
Like go play with your friends,
be a kid, be normal. Like wow.
Sound like there was times
that shit happen. And even now,
like I don't really do normal shit.
You know what I mean?
I might like go to the movies or like go
to Dave and Buster's or something like
that,
but like I don't do shit.
Like I just go to the studio much rather
just, you know what I mean? Create.
Well that's amazing that
you figured it out so young.
How old were you when you knew
you wanted to be a robber? Uh,
I think I was in third grade,
so real shit.
I think I was in third grade.
That's amazing. I want to,
I wanted to be an Ninja turtle and I
wanted to be a rapper and I think a rapper
was like a little bit more realistic.
I'm working on being a Ninja turtle now.
That's amazing. Fifth Grade, third
grade, third grade again, you're nine,
you're not. Yeah. Yeah.
That's when I started writing my
first raps and shit is hilarious.
I was like watching music videos and I
remember seeing like puffy and biggie
bone thugs and harmony is like one of
my favorite groups. So it was like, Yo,
if I could do that I'll
be high. And then, um,
by the time I was like 13,
uh,
that's when the Internet was really
popular so you could download like
instrumentals and shit like that.
So you didn't have to like have beats or
anything. Then they started introducing,
you know,
uh,
at home equipment they had like little
task him for track little bullshit thing
that you could, you know what I mean?
So I started fucking around on that.
Mike doing my own little home studio.
Then fruity loops came out,
started making beats. Cool.
Edit pro was like the,
the program back then
before protools and yeah,
that's how I got my start. Like just
in the fucking in the, in the crib,
just putting it together. Then I turned
like, then by the time I was like 16,
I got like an internship at a,
at a studio in Pittsburgh where I was
literally like answering the phones and
running errands and going to pick up
like office supplies and shit like that.
And in return they will
pay me with studio time.
So like I will just record like off,
you know what I mean? Off the clock.
You know what I mean?
I had like four or five songs and
that turned into the record. Do. Wow.
Yup. Got My first deal at 16 that's
an amazing story. That's wild.
That's, that's a movie story. That's
crazy. You always knew. Yeah. Yup.
It was something that I worked at for
sure cause it was like being in in
Pittsburgh. You ever
been to Pittsburgh? Yeah.
You know it's pretty crazy
out there. Right. Crazy.
How like it's just a really wild city,
like the Midwest.
So it's like there's either a couple of
things you can do and there's not a lot.
And working a job is like the last thing
that anybody wants to do in Pittsburgh.
So all my cousins and everybody that I
know do different shit than what I was
willing to do. I was like, Yo, I'm not
trying to be that guy. Like, like that.
So it was like, how am I going to make
a way for myself? You know what I mean?
How the fuck am I going to get still
be fresh still. You know what I mean?
Enjoy myself. Have a good time
but be safe and like have fun.
It was music so it's amazing.
You nailed and nailed it young.
Yup.
That's a beautiful thing to
know what you want to do. Yeah.
And just be working towards it. Have
for many people that's the real problem.
The real problem was like
finding a thing. Yeah. You know,
finding a thing that they really love so
much to fit all their energy into. Yeah.
I mean I'm blessed to grow up in a time
to where technology was like taking over
and shit and I think like if you're my
age and you like make music or got a
camera or you know what I mean?
Anything around that you good like
and now I think it's like if you have
anything to do with weed, like you know
what I'm saying? You're not to grow it.
If you could sell it,
if you could brand it,
if you could come up with light technology
or whatever it is like that's going
to be the future for this generation.
It's like pot.
This is going to be a lot of that for
sure. It's going to open up to everybody.
I think once they realize how much money
there really is and pot and how safe it
is in comparison to liquor and all
these other established things that we
evolved. No one has a problem with
alcohol companies, right? No, no, no.
Nobody has a problem with them.
Nobody has a problem with you drinking
at 12 in the fucking afternoon.
Like I get on planes all the time. People
will be like, Yo, let me get a little,
it's like people getting fucked up,
Yo on a plane. That's totally fine.
We just have to shift
attitudes. Yeah. Yup.
People just have the wrong
attitude about it. They,
they think it's something negative and
something that could be negative to some
people, but that's like
everything else. That's like
food, sex, gambling, everything,
shopping, everything. You had been
shopping for sure. People go crazy.
People lose their mind chopping.
Yeah. They can't buy enough things.
Buying crazy shit.
Just cause just cause yeah,
that's, that's as much of a
addiction as anything. Nope.
But pod can definitely for
some people derail them.
I don't think it's for
everybody. Nah, it's a medicine.
So you got the right dosage. That's,
that's a good way of looking at it.
I think some people react to it weird too.
Yeah.
I mean certain people's experiences
on everybody else's experience.
So it's like if you got fucked up
on weed, that's you. So I was like,
don't put that off on everybody else.
And I think like, like anything,
it takes time to,
you know what I mean?
Like I can't take Percocet because it's
like that shit will fuck me up cause I
don't do painkillers.
But I think over a certain amount of time,
if I had an injury,
my body will start to react differently
to certain amount of Percocet.
But like off rip,
it's gonna fuck me up.
You know what I'm saying
is I'm gonna throw up,
I'm going to do all types of
Shit. But you know, after awhile,
you know what I mean?
There's people who just popped that
shit and just walk around like,
you know what I mean? Normally, yeah.
That same way with me smoking a joint
and it's like there's some people who
could hit this and be in that corner
for the rest of the day. For me,
I'm going to go do everything that
I have to do. So it's a medicine,
it's a dosage and you have to train
your body for it. I think that's true,
but I also think some people might not
react to it correctly in terms of like
biologically. Yeah, I think
they might have an allergy.
Like it might be like
Broccoli or something.
There's people out there that are
allergic to weird shit. Right.
There's some people I think that just,
I've heard of that that experience
is just not good for their,
like they're allergic to it. I don't,
I mean, you know, I'm just guessing.
I don't know. I mean it made sense.
I think it's opinion like if you,
if you believe it or not, you know what I
mean? Like, if you want to believe that,
I feel like you're
entitled to believe that.
And if you don't want to believe that,
then it's like, okay, cool. You're,
you're that guy too.
Okay.
I don't know either what you said. Yeah.
I don't know. I don't know either bro,
because it's like I'm on the
fence because it's like, you know,
on one hand people, I mean, I
don't know. Fuck yeah, yeah.
Whatever. It's medicine. It's
fucking medicine. And I like it.
A lot of people that like it,
it's not what everybody thinks it is,
is wrong idea of it. One of the
things I found out real early on,
it's how many Jujitsu guys
smoke weed and do Jujitsu. Yeah.
You've seen the high rollers state?
Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Hi. Rowers has, uh,
all these awesome events where they do,
they smoke weed and then they fight
in a Jujitsu match. Yup. My partners,
uh, are, are, are a big part
of that. Lonnie and breeze.
And they're the ones who actually got
me like kind of, you know, into fitness.
So to see them like,
and I'm the one who got him in the weed.
So it's like to see it like crossover.
I never would have known like,
you know what I'm saying?
How many Jiu Jitsu dudes like smoke
weed and like our about it like, yeah,
the House that she helps her Jujitsu,
it really does.
It helps like slow it down for you. Right.
I don't even know if it's slow it down.
It's like a tunes out the rest of
the world. Like you me become freer.
It's very weird. Like more creative.
There's, it's definitely uh,
it's better for rolling
than it is for drilling guy.
Just like when someone's
trying to teach you something,
sometimes your brain's just not just
hide, your brain's not taking in.
But if you were sparring it would be good.
Got You. You just, you flow better. Yeah.
Yeah.
That makes sense. That makes
sense. I haven't done Jujitsu yet.
I'm gonna get there eventually.
You would love it and
you've got long limbs, man.
You'd be perfect for choking people.
Yep. Armbars triangles and shit.
And I'm going to get there. You could
do it. Yup. I told like bill for it.
I feel like I'm going to just fuck with
stand up for like a couple of years and
then just gradually do other
things like, and I'm saying, yeah,
I'll just probably do Jujitsu for
like four or five years. Yeah.
And for sure you should just learn some
shit. Yeah, that'd be great for you man.
Yeah.
You're like I said,
you're built for it almost the perfect
frame for fighters as long it seems to be
a long, as long as you're strong.
It's like the John Jones frame.
That's the perfect frame, right? It's,
you can't get close enough to him.
He can hit you when he wants to and
then when he grabs a hold of you,
he's strong enough and he's better at
wrestling. He's going to throw you around.
Like if you could come up
like that's the perfect,
the perfect combination as long
and strong. Oh yeah. Perfect. Yeah.
Tweet dude's like [inaudible] they,
they bucked that trend,
right because it just tanks.
But the best I,
it seems to me like just mechanically
than best frame is the long frame.
So you have like the best frame for
fighting. Fuck graduations. Thank you.
I'm in there.
It doesn't guarantee success,
but it's a fucking awesome base. There we
go. I'm starting. I'm working with some.
Yeah. Yeah. Just like short dudes like
me can't put big guys and dry angles.
I was going to have enough leg room
does not enough. Like mechanically.
I'm sure you could figure
it out. Not really. Yeah.
Is he going to give up on that one?
But a long guys can get triangles
from all kinds of places. Okay.
You'd love it. Super. It's
a thinking man's game too.
You know? It's like, are you,
you're playing a game.
Yeah. You know? Yeah.
The thing that I like about it too
is that you can go full blast. Okay.
Whereas like if you're sparring,
you don't really want to go full
blast or hurt each other. Right.
You want to be tempered, measured,
and just kind of touch each other.
But when you do sparring in Jujitsu,
silly because you're not striking each
other. You just wrestling and grappling.
You can go full blast. Okay.
That's amazing. I'm with
it, bro. I'm super with it,
like the little bit that I've done, I was
like, all right, cool. I could see. Right.
Yeah. And I mean, yeah,
yeah, yeah. I'm down.
Okay.
Definitely got to go there.
I just love the fact that
you're interested in doing
different things. Yeah,
for sure. So I'm alerted. Do
you do read books? Do you, uh,
do you watch documentaries?
I watch documentaries. Yeah.
I have read some books,
uh,
that I gravitate towards. What kind of
documentaries you gravitate towards?
Dyke music really always
about, always about music. Um,
let me see what else. Yeah,
it's always about music.
Like musicians searching for sugar man.
What was that one that was about this
dude who was a guy who was making music?
I F belong,
I want to say it was in the 70s and he
had a like a little bit of buzz on his
album and then it died off for him and
he went back to work as a construction
worker,
but his music became insanely
huge in South Africa.
He was a superstar and there was all
these legends about him that he was dead.
That, you know, the, just the, just crazy
stories about who we was. Me and mom,
this guy was working as a construction
worker, so in South Africa,
he's a fucking mega superstar,
like sells out arenas and spoiler alert,
it's a great documentary.
Should see it,
but he eventually goes to South Africa
and does this concert there. You'll cry,
you'll cry. You're like, oh my God.
Can you imagine this guy was working
as a laborer? And the whole time was,
he was a superstar and he didn't
even know it. And the people see him,
they're singing along to his
music. I mean, the guys blown
away. I would love that.
It's a crazy document. I checked that
out. It, it's, it's insane to watch.
Like how could this be true?
Eh, Eh, Dale, it's amazing.
I kind of feel like I heard
the name, but I never, never,
never got to watch it grow. Yeah. It
made me cry. I gotta check that out.
At the end of it, you'd be like, wow,
I'll Haley hajj in this guy's experience.
They almost like being released from
jail or something. Yeah, exactly. Damn.
Yeah. That's incredible. Holy Fuck.
Yeah, I'm gonna check that out ma.
And seeing how comfortable
he gets on stage to wow.
There's amazing dam. Yeah. His
music is good too, man. Varying.
Very interesting. Is he still alive?
I believe he is alive. That's fine.
He's alive, right? Yeah.
So he's able to see the proceeds from
his movie and his, yeah. Hell yeah.
But someone said, I think he
gave away all his money. Really?
I read something about that might be more
of those rumors and legends allege on
another myth. Damn sure. Yeah.
Jamie, find out that dude gave his money
away cause I felt like I read that.
I was like, Bro. But life to
him is so surreal. Anyway,
truth maybe he felt like he couldn't be
a real bonafide artist unless he gave
away his money or something
crazy because you've got,
the guy was living in like this.
That's why I don't want to do
Iowasca or anything like that. God,
I feel like that's what's
going to happen to me.
You want to give away your money here?
Fuck that shit was like, whoa. No, no,
no, no. That's hilarious. It's too
tricky. You could, you could get, so,
you know, so, so charity driven,
just give away everything and
then you're working for charities,
which is walking the earth barefoot
to her last year to run theaters all
over the good shit. Sugarman. He's back.
He's back. He's smacking her
so much. That documentary did,
he gave away all his money yet.
Dave Matthews covered one of his songs
and then went on to help blow him up.
Oh Man. Oh yeah. Damn.
You just doing good.
So he ain't giving away nothing beautiful.
He might have,
but I don't see anything back.
Yeah,
it's,
the documentary is really amazing.
That's one of the best music documentaries
I've ever seen. Perfect. Thank you.
Yeah, that's a good one. Tell me a
good one. My documentary. Oh man,
it's called behind the camera.
Yeah. So apple music. Oh, okay.
Yeah, just did that. I just did that.
I just did that.
Beautiful Man. Not um, I like to watch,
like I watch this pink Floyd documentary
about how they put together, uh,
their albums, shit like that. Um,
there's another one about like, uh,
background singers who never liked,
became super popular.
But they're like potter part of uh,
songs that you hear and that you love.
And it's just like telling them the story,
like how writers and you know what
I mean? Being in studio, home wit,
it's like to live that life.
It's really cool cause I
listen to the harmonies a lot.
I don't know if when you hear music
I hear like all the textures of it.
So it's like I get interested in what
goes on sometimes like in the background.
And that was a cool story.
I'm fucking,
what was the last one that I
actually watched? I just watched,
I'm watching this show actually. You
ever heard Trenoble hurt? Hardly shows.
Amazing that shit. It's kind of cool. I
heard it's great man. It's pretty awesome.
But that's not music though. What
is that on? Is that Netflix, HBO,
Hbo Coming Back,
game of Thrones didn't kill him to Nobu.
Is it really? Yeah. Good. I'll
show lit. It's all you need.
Here's a big show in HBO is back.
Chernobyl.
What is it about the, the accident? Yeah.
How many episodes is it? I'm not
sure. They're like streaming them now.
So it's like, oh, it's streams. Yeah. Yup.
It's on like the fourth or fifth episode.
I think all those networks
that don't stream everything.
Yeah. Like they must be,
it must suck to have like a show that
has to be on Thursday night at eight
losing out just today.
So weird man.
Want to watch things whenever
they want it right now? Yes,
for sure. Five apartment, new series.
The last episode is coming up this week.
Oh, okay. There you go. How do you think
the movie theaters were always be here?
Mm hmm. Shit. Nah, I want
that thing. Eventually.
Ain't gonna be gone. What do you think?
I don't know. Just it's one of the,
I kind of, I liked it. They're
real, you know, there's a,
a place you go, they're already
kind of came and gone twice.
If you look around all the Hollywood,
there's old theaters that
aren't theaters anymore,
but there's new theaters
that have taken over them.
But those buildings are still there for
whatever reason. I still use the number.
Well, people still like going to the
movies. It's like a, it's a night out
saying, yeah. You know,
I go like it costs so much
to like keep screening,
actually put movies in and then you
got the popcorn.
It's like,
but it's one of the few things that we
do in with strangers is like be a part of
an audience. It's like one
thing, the few things we ran,
we do at giant groups of strangers.
I feel like technology is like removing
that because people don't like that.
I think people are uncomfortable with
it because most of the time we spend on
devices for communicating through
devices and especially with like virtual
reality becoming more popular.
You know,
like people love access.
So it was like if you're making them
feel like they're, they're like,
why would you want random dude walking
across your lap when you can just be in
the movie? Like yeah, I feel like they
would just spend to spend that money on,
you know, keeping you at home, like where
you want to be. That's just my opinion.
I don't know. No, I think you're right.
And I agree with you 100% but I also
think as a community of human beings,
it's nice to have things that
we all do together. Yeah.
It fosters like a kind of getting along
better and friendship. I love that.
People that you don't know.
I think that's what's good about sports.
I like concerts because of
the concerts. Yeah. Yeah.
When you go to grow the whole group of
people to see something like it's nice
you connect to tell you it feels good.
Baseball Games cause I've had fun at
games and I gave a fuck about what was
going on, but it's the community
that was going on for sure.
100% that's what I mean. I mean never
everyone's kind of drinking. I'm fun.
That is an important part of cities.
Communities.
That's one thing that I think that or
like a movie theater does provide. Yeah.
I mean for sure.
Concert for sure.
And I'm not even mad that people don't
really go to the movies like that now
because it's like when you
actually do want to go,
you can go and it's not full and it's not,
you know what I mean?
Like it'll be people there,
but it's not overwhelming to
the point where you got like,
it fucks up your movie experience.
So it's like, it's kind of, you know,
it's doable. It's enjoyable.
It's handleable. Yeah.
Yeah. It's cool. It's fun.
I like where the movies is that right
now I am worried that people are
eventually going to all be living in
some sort of a VR world. Yeah. I mean,
I feel like it's designed to move that
way. Like, you know what I'm saying?
Like you give people something
and they're going to use it
and they're going to get better.
Yeah. A new one. Yeah. Yeah.
It was going to have extra features. Yeah.
So it's like, all right, like, you know,
I get it. Like, fuck, have you fucked with
any of that VR stuff? Yeah. VR is awesome.
Do you ever do that? There's a thing
outside of Disneyland where you uh,
there's a VR game that you go through.
You go through like this little like they
have a like a giant room and the room
set up for them. What it was they called
the void. Is that what it's called? Yeah.
Holy Shit. Void VR. And there's a star
wars one and there's a wreck it Ralph one.
Okay. And they're hilarious. I
mean you're, you're walking around,
you feel heat from fire, they
pick up a gun, you shooting
at storm troopers and it's crazy.
It's crazy. And while you're doing it,
you'd like, this is just step
one. Exactly. This is going to be,
is saying there's one a year in
those pieces. Bits and pieces.
It's like they already have more.
Do you think that Oh for show 100%
I don't think that really. Yeah,
cause I think that what they're showing
you right now, state of the art,
they're selling it. It's the best.
Again, that's in competition.
It's getting better and
better all the time.
But that's a good way to look at it
because they put it up myself, my find me.
No worries man. Yeah. I just think these
people were very competitive. Yeah.
The money is in getting the best
shit out the quickest. Okay.
And they're all competing with each other.
So they're putting out like the bootleg
virgin and letting somebody smarter,
uh, test it, work it and
make the better version.
Then they'll come back and do that later.
Well that definitely happens to,
I mean that's a what China
does better than anybody.
I take some shit and just redo it.
I'd be feeling like, this is just,
my theory is like VR.
Right?
It might be so fucking dangerous that
they don't know like how it will live it
out. Yeah, exactly.
So it's like they give us like little
bits and pieces of it. Let us, you know,
they spoonfeed it to us so they don't
kill us and the world just go crazy.
And it's like, you know what I mean? Like,
cause they probably tested it on
somebody and they died like Taylor.
You know what I mean? For sure. Yeah.
They was like, Oh shit, we went too far.
It's like, oh, let's like pull it back
a little bit and just give them this,
like you said, give them this version
of it. You know what I mean by,
I feel like there's more,
well, I think when they,
when you really don't know what the fuck
is going on, that's with military stuff.
I think military stuff
like weapons and you know,
space ships and aircraft
that they're developing.
We don't know what the fuck they're doing.
They're doing some shit
that we have no idea.
But I think with things like consumer
electronics, like technology,
I think what you see is what you get.
I think this is as good as
they can do anything. Now.
They're working on the newest best shit.
Right. You know, and that's coming around.
They're always constantly in development,
but they're all competing
against each other.
There is no way they would
hold anything back. Really?
Yeah. I don't think so. Damn.
I feel like there's a phone that
charges in two seconds. It's like, okay,
if you're way you didn't have it
out if you're in a war. Right.
And your cellular device goes down.
It's like you can't plug it in and charge
it. It, it has to like happen quick.
Right, right. So like they have that, in
my opinion, they just don't give it to us.
But that all that stuff, the, I
can see your argument because it's,
you're in a war.
They might have better batteries like
that the military develops or some new
kind of battery that's possible.
But there's so much money in batteries.
Like there's so much money.
If they had a better way of doing it,
right. If Samsung came out with a phone,
right.
Charged 100% in 30 seconds and it you,
apple would have to do it. I have to
figure out how to compete with them.
They would have that out. Right.
I wouldn't hold onto that.
No one would hold on to that because
that would just dominate the market.
It would dominate the market
too. Powerful. But that happens.
That's what always happens to me. That's
how blockbusters out of business. Right.
You know? Right, right, right, right.
That's why there's no more tower records.
I'll let,
I'll let shit happen in our lifetime.
Yeah. For show like 100% music
isn't even physical. Right. Like,
and I make music in this.
It's not real. Right.
It's a sound.
It's a sound and fuck,
you know,
I don't know.
That is a crazy way to look at music.
[inaudible] what is this?
The [inaudible] 17 pro,
which the company's latest is the
fastest charging smartphone in the world.
It advertises that 35 minutes is all it
takes to entirely fill up a dead battery
seven months ago. So, so it's probably
faster than again, something like that.
For sure. 35 minutes. So what do you think
they can do? Like for a full battery,
I would say that there's probably a
hundred cell phones out there that can
charge in five minutes.
There's not a million, cause
they can't source that much.
Maybe charge more than
this, Ken. Like yeah,
I would say like there's a military phone
that they might have a hundred of them
around the military, but it's not mass
produced can charge up in five minutes.
Sure. For sure. For sure.
If this can do 35 minutes,
Youtube,
she's seven times fast.
You guys are all good spirit
toward [inaudible]. It's
just, yeah, I mean to meet as normal
leap to me, that shit is normal.
This is energy that we're talking
about. Right, right, right bro.
Like cars still move off of gas.
Like that shirt.
It's like the stone age Bro.
Like shit's going electric.
You know what I'm saying? Like that's
awesome. Spaceships Shit. So they,
I mean like at the end of the day,
like they have this shit,
they just can't give it to you because
they, they're killing people testing it.
It's like, it's like food,
you know what I mean?
Like they have to approve
this shit before it comes out.
But they have a car that goes,
it just crashed into the wall,
you know what I mean?
And somebody died in and they're like,
well we can't put this on the streets yet.
It's like all of that shit energy.
Yeah. Like, well you think
they have a car that's so fast,
they can't put it on the street.
They had,
I just feel like transportation
in general. You know what I mean?
Communication, transportation,
technology. The way we hear music,
the way that we do things
and shit like that.
Our whole experience,
tech, technology, tick,
whatever the fucking word is,
we're being spoonfed, facetime.
You know what I'm saying?
It was like you used to have to
have the service to facetime.
Now everybody can facetime.
You know what I mean?
It's like people don't even call each
other no more. They just facetime,
so we feel like, oh man, came up
this, this is blah, blah, blah.
Like we feel good about that.
We feel excellent about it,
but there's more.
I feel like that's just me. I just
feel like they're just sitting on it.
You know what I mean?
They're waiting to give it to us.
I don't think companies have
any reason to do that. Yeah.
The only reason to do that would be to
get rid of the stock of the stuff that
they're already selling.
That'd be the only reason.
Cause sometimes when companies
announce a new products,
common people stopped
buying the old product.
Like corvette is having a
problem with that right now.
Cause the corvette [inaudible] excuse me.
They got in this car, the Zr one thing.
It's a demon.
It's ridiculous.
So you could go to a store and buy
a car that has that much horsepower,
but a lot of people don't want to buy
them because then there's a new corvette
coming out in like a year.
That's a mid engine total read new design
that we want to be stuck with the old
one. Gotcha. People get weird.
Yeah, that's true. So in that sense,
they might be holding out on what
they're about to be able to do,
but like we saw with that foldable phone
at Samsung tried to come out with and
then they had to take it back
because it was so defective.
So many of them were breaking.
It was a giant embarrassment and they
pulled the whole thing and now they're
trying to rework it and
figure out what to do with it.
That that's like if a company
has something like that happen,
and that's the number two smartphone
company in the world. They're number one,
right? Samsung's number one while
ways number two, apples number three.
That's a number one cell
phone manufacturer in the
world and they got that kind
of a fuck up. There's no way they're not
holding back anything. I don't think so.
I think they're trying to sell the
best shit they have right now and then
they're in development with
the next level shit right now.
But as far as like what they can bring
to market but they have is what they
bring to market.
I think like those onscreen fingerprint
sensors that didn't use to be able to do
that and now they can just touch
the glass and it reads it all.
That shit is like,
they're just trying to get it dialed in
to the point where they could sell it to
enough people and it doesn't
break like that stupid folding.
Did you see that folding screen is like
a fucking like it was a regular phone
but it folded them. Yeah, it would fold up
into like an iPad. IPAD, yeah. Yup. Yeah.
That's just stupid.
But that thing kept breaking and you
know when it came out everybody was like,
Holy Shit, this is the future. The Glass
Benz. I think there's like, like you said,
there's like the, the, the people who just
freak out about whatever's new, right.
And then there's like, shit that really
moves the, you know what I'm saying? Like,
like really changes shit.
You know what I mean? Sure.
And there's a huge
difference between those.
Like you've got the people who just
want the new shit and then you got
motherfuckers who's actually like
doing shit that changes things forever.
Like streaming changed music forever,
you know what I'm saying?
So it's like many discs and all of
that other stupid shit that people were
trying to do to change music. It
didn't work. You know what I mean?
And it didn't exist.
So it's like the one thing that
stands out and changes things forever.
That's what motherfuckers remember.
I don't know if they're holding it or not.
It is what it is. But like there's
some smart motherfuckers who
designed this shit for us, you know what
I'm saying? And at the end of the day,
like the pit, you got people who just
consume it and they're just like, aw man,
I'm here for, for whatever,
whatever. Like you know what I mean?
And then I feel like there's a lot of
people who understand it and know how to
play off of,
you know what I mean?
Those people's emotions and that's where
you get like, you know what I mean?
What we have now and me personally,
I love everything.
Like I'm not a person who like it stuck
with the old shit or has to have all of
the new shit either. Like I'm just
like obsessed with life in general.
Like all of this shit fucks me up.
But it's crazy.
It's insane. We living in same
time, we live in an insane time.
What's cool about today too is that we
can go and still like appreciating you
some of the shit from the past. Like
a record player. Yeah. User record.
Listen to some old records. Right.
You know and realize like, wow,
this is how people used to get their
music sit in front of the record player
with headphones on. I remember being a
kid doing that would listen to the album.
They open up the all album looking at
the art. That was a big part of an album.
Right. What was the photo layout?
What was the, the pictures were,
it's crazy how everybody thinks like
the new shit ruins the older shit too.
Right. It's like people still enjoy
everything. Yeah. Like you know,
it's just stages of it. I love that.
That old should exist. Yeah. Hell yeah.
Go back and listen to
some of that old stuff.
People don't watch tapes anymore though.
Like you can't get like a VHS like that.
That's not the move.
Yeah.
Those are dead and gone be h s c h and
when someone would give you a copy of a
copy and it was all like every now and
then I have a little lines through and
shit. You get like second, third
generation copies of friends. Yeah.
Vhs is are done, bro. Even me, I
don't know if you remember this,
but you used to be able to buy
movies right after they came out,
especially in New York because dudes would
sit in the back of the movie theater.
I like the little bootleg
joints. Yeah, Yup. Yeah. And
watched the movie from like,
it was like a video camera and be
like in their video in the movie.
Yeah, that was, that was crazy.
That was a crazy time. Yeah.
They weren't hiding shit back then.
They were using all of their technology.
That's everything.
They had everything they fucking had.
The crazy thing is that not that
long ago per terms of the human race.
That's not that long ago. That's the
nineties that's, that's so recent.
This is what,
2019 so I 20 years.
So you go back 2124 years maybe.
And I imagine if you could see what the
fuck 24 years from now is just crazy.
I've related to like when I was younger
in the 90s cause I was like a baby in
the 90s I wasn't even a teenager.
So 20 years from this was the
70s and shit was totally like,
you know what I'm saying?
So it's like now from 20 years from
to for that to be the same time frame.
Like that shit is crazy me.
You really
want to know how crazy it is man.
Get yourself into like a 1970 Plymouth
and drive that thing and realize that in
1970 [inaudible] that's how people drove.
They drive this thing,
they like it barely knows where, where
your talents are. Yeah. Hell yeah.
I could do this with the steering
wheel steering in the 60s and Shit Bro.
Like you're ready to turn the thing. A
lot of them didn't, a lot of them didn't.
But do you use,
those cars were terrible and
that was just a few years ago.
I mean in terms of like human history,
right?
If you looked at a block
of time in history,
like if you looked up difference between
1820 and 1840 and our head it's like
that's the same shit.
1820 1840 what the fuck was different?
There was nothing different.
But if you look at our
generation 40 years ago to now,
it's insane. It's true. That's insane.
It doesn't even make sense. It's nuts.
It's a bear. We're barely
the same thing, bro.
It's crazy. It's crazy.
Have you driven a Tesla?
No, I have it. That good. The
preposterous to preposterous car.
What's the deal with them? That's so
fast. It doesn't make sense really.
Every other car you drive afterwards,
we'll feel stupid. You could drive mine.
You've got Tesla. Yeah. Yeah. You
could drive it there. That legit.
It's the most ridiculous thing I've
ever driven in my life. Fuck did.
It doesn't make any noise.
It doesn't make, it makes
zero noise. This makes noise.
It's a fucking rap
music video.
Entourage
style.
Girls in their underwear house
dancing bottle of champagne.
Girl in my house so much.
Just follow you.
The camera just to see who rings
your doorbell, right? I don't know.
I know who that girl was at the party.
What were we just talking about?
Teslas. Oh yeah. Yeah. It's a spaceship.
It's next level.
If you think that they're holding
back anything in the automotive world,
drive that thing and you'll see
Nah, that's, that's the thing.
I feel like all cars are going to look
alike and they're gonna look like Teslas.
So you're going to have the super fast
one for like the elite motherfuckers,
but then they don't have like regular
ones and then we're all going to have the
same car or we're all going to have the
same phone where I'm going to have the
same watch and we'll all,
because it controls everything.
Like they control your house. So it's
like everything is integrated. The TV,
the Xbox,
it's like you all wanted in one.
So the only way to do that is
for everything to be the same.
So like if the Tesla,
is that ill,
I never drove driven one
but if it's that ill,
I don't see why people wouldn't be into
it. Like it's just a pain in the asses.
It takes a long time to charge it.
I mean even if you have a
Tesla supercharger thing,
like I have one on a wall mounted
charger that's, it's like more amps type.
It's nice, but it still takes a few
hours to charge if it's almost dead.
Whereas you can get gas like five
minutes. Exactly. Portable chargers.
No, no, no. They ain't do [inaudible]. No,
you need insane amount of
power to power that thing.
But how long giant batteries in it
just takes hours and hours to fill up.
That doesn't sound like fun.
Well,
because it goes 317 miles to see
this race they did with the tunnel.
Two Teslas at the same spot, like I guess
it's in Hawthorne where they have it.
The one on the right is using the tunnel.
They haven't completed in the one
the left is going above ground. No.
Is this tunnel like auto drive?
It's got fuck things got those tracks on
the side so that it can stay in place.
Look how fast ads going 127 miles an hour.
So not comfortable with that and it
slows right down the way that it moves
differently. That's how robots are
gonna kill us as crazy. It's so fast.
You can't believe how fast it is.
That guy's not moving at the top.
And the guy's moving very fast.
Takes him four and a half minutes to go
the same time. It takes six guy a minute.
That guy's battery's dead as fuck
on the right. I'll tell you that.
If you stop on that thing for that long,
you better be prepared for
that shit to drink quick.
Especially when it's in ludicrous mode.
That's what they call it. Ludicrous mode.
Yeah, and now they have
ludicrous. Plus I'm,
I don't even want to turn that shit on.
I don't need that. What kind of assholes?
Unhappy with ludicrous
mode was gonna ask before.
Don't you think there's some car
company trying to beat them? Yeah.
Has to be right. Tesla has a roadster
or have you seen the Tesla roadster?
Oh my God. Jamie pulled
that up. It's a spaceship.
It's this little sports car looking
spaceship that goes zero to 60 in 1.9
seconds. It's a spaceship.
It's a spaceship.
That's the Tesla roadster. I like
that. It's a dope look and little car.
The roof comes off too. As Real,
Huh? Oh my God. That thing's a demon,
I think is a dean.
How much of that because
I think it's $200,000 it's
real. Yeah. It's not out yet.
I'm working on it. Oh, okay.
They're working on releasing
it soon. Yeah. 200 grand.
Look at that 1.9 seconds. Zero
to 60 yeah. I don't need that.
They just seem the electric cars, it
seemed like the future. But again,
that one's going to be interesting
because it has 600 miles.
It goes 660 miles I think
without, uh, without charging,
which is long distance minds
and like 317 the new ones,
the ones that have now like
three 17 that's dope, man.
That's amazing. It's wild.
Like my mind is literally blown
by this shit. Yeah. I mine too.
Like for real,
like that shit blows Madsen.
Imagine if you one of those people
that makes those things. Yeah.
Like that's your job.
I feel like it's like really a
process like scientific like,
you know, cause you don't want nobody to
hurt themselves. You know what I mean?
So you have to get it just right. Sure.
It's like, what's the process of that?
Like,
what are the fuck are they doing like
with technology and and electricity in a
car? Yeah, and they have
all the, all these safety
features. They have auto drive.
That's itself saying it's going to be so
fast. Guy Have Hell safety. Jesus Christ.
I'm just going to let you in. I can't
turn this thing off. Oh, there it is.
The same girl. I don't know. She's
persistent. She's a go getter.
I don't know.
She need to go get something else,
but yeah man.
I mean it's when you drive something
like that and you realize like, oh, okay,
just 30 40 years ago, cars were these
stinky, weird things that barely steered,
right?
And now you have these things that it
seemed like it seemed like there from a
futuristic movie and you can
get them right now. It's crazy.
Like it's insane because people like,
okay,
where are we going to be
without transportation? We
got to go somewhere. Right?
We got to get there somehow.
What is this, Jamie?
I was looking up.
I thought I saw something today
about a Lamborghini electric car,
but this fell into this hole of
the tourism. Millennials, some new,
it is an electric car.
Buy a Lamborghini that self heals.
It has some sort of carbon fiber
technology that allows it to fix itself.
If it cracks watts dry,
I don't know.
Oh yes.
We text cracks and damages to go.
It's a fucking transformer. The
transformer, it's going to heal itself.
That I was hoping you had heard of it.
No. Self healing. Oh my God. There we go.
It's going to fix itself.
Sorry to distract from that,
but yeah, it's Italian,
right? Yeah. Listen to me. That's
my people. It ain't gonna work.
Those savages.
It looks insane though.
This they're thinking big. If you'd want
to go on a long trip and a Lamborghini,
you're out of your fucking mind.
That thing.
We'll leave you in the middle of the
desert. They thinking B. That's it. Yeah.
That is a, it's got these weird, crazy,
unbelievably good looking car tires. Damn,
that looks like the future. That's fine.
Look at that thing. Suspicious Shit.
But you, if you take one of those, you
know that it's made by Italians. Right?
You know, like, like, oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's the accident with the car. It
makes sense. It's so flamboyant.
Look at the wheels on that thing. What
the fuck is with those wheels? Wow.
That's crazy. And Italian
spaceship. Yeah. Yeah.
Cars are getting closer and
closer to spaceships. Yeah.
What do people start flying around?
You comfortable with that?
I'm not want anybody to landing
on my house. Landing on the house.
Air Accidents. Yeah, man,
those don't seem too good. No.
In the regulation of
what lane do you stay,
because we worked so hard to
develop these roads. It's like,
well where are we going now?
Like what's going on here?
You imagine if we had like a floating
bubble highway system, right?
Like there's balloons held on by row by
rope that go all the way to the ground
and that marks the past where you're
allowed to fly your flying car through.
But people don't look and they
slamming each other and no man,
you're out there in the park with your
kids regulation with suck on that. Yeah,
man. Sure. How do you stop people
from, they would have to be autonomous.
Who would have to be
like Tesla auto drive,
so just takes you up and
it just brings you around.
We'd have to be something like
that. That makes sense. Yeah. You,
we couldn't leave it up to
people not with flying. Hell No.
It's to me different personalities.
Yeah.
But then there's going to be lazy people
that don't charge their fucking flying
car and then it gets up there and it's
like that did that, did that, that,
that like you didn't charge it.
You shouldn't be able to take off if
it's not at a certain, if it's, if it's,
if it's capable of dying.
I agree.
Grounded then when you're
gonna need more regulation,
so we have more government
[inaudible] air laws have to,
that's the only way we need more
government. More regulations. Air Cops,
Eric. Oh my gosh. They're police.
Listen to talk about those gaps.
Please. Still be even on more on edge.
They ground in the ground police. Yeah.
Yeah. Cause they're in
the air. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
They're probably going to be super
paranoid up there for sure. For sure.
Well, if we ever do eventually
get to space travel,
if human beings ever do figure out how
to like go to other planets and set up a
civilization on Mars
or something like that,
that's probably what the real next level
future of humanity's going to be other
than artificial life. If we can really
figure out how to set up a base somewhere.
Do you think you would ever go
if there was a base on Mars,
it takes six months to go to Mars. If
there was a threat on earth, a threat.
Yeah. It was like Yo earth is not
to be fucked up like an asteroid.
Yeah, I would. You know, I
would if Mars was all right,
I would try to go, I will take my
family and go, yeah, totally. Wow.
To save my family. That makes sense. To
save your family. Yeah. What if, yeah.
What if Mars was awesome? What if they
figured it out? If it was awesome. Yeah.
I'd rather just die on hers.
Yeah, I'm cool here. I'm good.
Yeah.
I just wonder once they actually do
start going from Earth to other planets,
how many people are going
to be willing to do that?
All the rich folks you think so?
I think rich folks want to go into orbit.
I don't think they want to go to Mars.
I don't think there's a whole lot of
live there. Maybe if you can come back.
Let's say we're far in the
future vacation. Yeah. Take
a little vacation to Mars.
It takes six months to get there.
Everybody think if it takes six
months to get there, hold on.
That's another one's a long I think.
I think a lot of people would do that.
I think a lot of people would do it.
I think you're right.
If they knew they could come back because
then they'd be able to brag about it.
People would love to brag about going
to Mars just like that time travel thing
where like take six earth months to get
there, but for you it's like two weeks.
Ooh. I don't think it
works that way, but yeah,
I was wondering how does that have to be
like at the speed of light for that to
happen? Yeah. Mm. Yeah. Now
we're getting deep. Interesting.
You might be able to go save some time
if you go do that months lose some time
though.
I know that's a fact.
Like if you go into space
at a particularly high
rate of speed and then you
figured out how to come back,
like your brother,
your twin brother would be way
older than you. Yeah. Damn.
Yeah, that makes sense. I went
to see this Brian Cox show.
Do you know Brian Cox is
astrophysicists?
He had a show he did in La and in the
back they have this gigantic screen and
it's this real high resolution screen
and it showed all of the galaxies in the
universe.
It showed all of them that you know,
just all jammed in together with like
appropriate space in between them and you
look at it and you just go,
what w what the fuck is that?
Like we're in that thing.
We're one.in just trillions of
dots of all these other galaxies.
Dan, through the known universe. I've
never seen anybody show it that way.
And one of the things he talked about
was that the rate of time is not the same
for each person.
Even on earth.
Like depending on where you go and what
you do and what speed you travel at.
If you and I were born on the exact same
day and we both got to watch and that
watch was perfectly calibrated and you
put your watch on and I put my watch on
and we met when we're 80 if
our watches are still working,
the time would be different because
we've lived through different time and it
might be only incremental,
a tiny increment like a
second or a couple seconds,
but enough so that in the whole
unit and I was high as fuck.
So while I'm there watching this thing,
the whole thing just blew me away.
I was like, this is a crazy way to look
at the universe. This is it right there.
Yeah. If anybody gets a chance, if you,
that's just one galaxy that
they're showing that was,
it's a one Gaussi colliding with another
galaxy. It's fucking spectacular. Whoa.
Yeah.
Do you get into space?
Documentaries Mountain? You got to,
I just don't believe everything
that everybody tells me.
So what about shit like that?
So I would have to get it
from a reliable sports source.
You would have to tell me like the
good, okay. Space Shit. And he,
Neil degrasse Tyson ones. Um, uh,
Lawrence Krauss has got some good stuff.
He's got good audio books too. Um, that
Brian Cox guides as good as it guys.
He's a genius.
He used to be a musician is actually in
like a a pop band thinking the eighties
and the eighties. Yeah. Like
a popular pop band and uh,
he's a legit astrophysicist. He
just talks about space. Yeah.
He gives these very entertained with this
Guy Robin Inns and they have this like
stage show and you know, he comes out and
talks about things and explains things.
But explain when he explained that time
thing to me that if we live the same
life that our watches would be
different. Yeah. That's crazy.
I love shit like that. I'm writing
his name down. Brian Cox. Cox,
not like the dicks. Yeah, I don't,
I wouldn't put that name in there.
Of course
that could be a problem. Ah, yeah. If you
get a chance to see that show, man, it's,
it's a,
it's a good thing to see too,
because it's so different than anything
else you go to see. Like for me,
I'm always at comedy clubs.
I'm always, you know,
either in the audience or on stage.
So to be there at this place in the
audience of this weird kind of like show
slash science seminar, it's
amazing. It's tight. Yeah.
That shit seems crazy as fuck
to learn and laugh. Yeah.
I gotta I gotta get you on some
science documentaries. Hell yeah.
When you're smoking weed and
watching science documentaries,
that's helped my music that's in
the real thoughts come out. Kids,
we realize there's no
getting away. If you, if you,
you know that paranoid feeling that
you get sometimes you get too high.
If you have that paranoid feeling combined
with a science documentary on space,
then you realize, yeah, we're
moral. Very insignificant. Exactly.
And you seem extra high cause you're
high watching space. It's like, Yo,
this dude is stolen.
How have you gotten high your whole life?
I started when I was 16 when you were
16 that started smoking every day.
Wow. So right around the time where you
were becoming successful as a rapper,
it was really like high school because
I hated school and I was just so done
with it and I was selling pot and my
mom found out and she was low key.
Just super cool with it. It was
like, oh like I smoke, you smoke,
we smoke. And you know what I mean? Wow.
It actually helped me get through school,
like to make it made it tolerable,
like, you know what I mean? Sure.
I was able to deal with like the shit
that I did want to deal with it because
I'm an intelligent kid.
I just really didn't like school.
I didn't like the school that I went
to was good. I went to a nice school,
but it was just, I grew up in a time where
it was like, you know what I'm saying?
Was we weird so well,
every school for every kid,
it's not what you want to do every day.
It was just not what you
want to do every day.
And like you got teachers who say certain
things to you and it's like, all right,
I understand what I'm really here for.
You know what I mean?
And I see who I am to you
and you let it be known.
It's kind of hard to like take those
people serious and want to do the work,
you know,
want to follow their lead man.
It's like for me that was the bare
minimum was like graduated high school.
I was like, I could move on with the
rest of my fucking life after that. Yeah,
we'd helped me get through high school.
I would say that for everybody.
I ain't gonna say it for everybody that
helped me. I believe you. Yeah. Yeah,
that makes sense. Cause there's a
lot of shit that's not that fun,
but when you're high becomes
interesting. A lot of shit. Yeah. Yup.
That's why air travel, air
travel is always better when
you're high, way better.
Way Better. You can take
the pills, you have edibles,
you do whatever you want to come. Like
appreciative of the experience. Exactly.
Yeah. Yup. Let's be
up there flying for real.
Yeah.
There's something to me about music,
listening to music too,
and a plane while you're high to
say that has like extra impact,
like headphones on a plane
surrounded by all these people.
No one's talking flying through the sky,
going 500 miles an hour and 30,000 feet
above the rocks and then the music kicks
in. Yeah. Yep.
Something about old music too far for me.
Like,
like lately I've been getting into a
lot of like really old rock and roll,
you know,
just,
just imagining what it would be like to
like to be around those people alone.
You know. See Keith Richards and
Mick Jagger in the 70s, you know,
to see little Richard and to
see James Brown live. Hell yeah.
James Brown performed a live
God. Yup. There was nothing,
it's hard for us to imagine there was
nothing like that before them. You know,
like there's,
there's levels of like impact that those
early musicians have that it's hard to
really historically put into place because
there wasn't anybody like them before
that nope. No rock and
roll stars. No rap stars.
Think of how recent that is. Yeah. That's
super new. Standup comedy is only about
maybe like 70 years old or some shit
like that. Maybe. Maybe. Really.
Maybe you could say a hundred if you
want to get crazy. But rappers like 30,
30 years old, 40 maybe, maybe four. Yeah.
Aa and it keeps evolving.
Keeps a Bob and Jim.
Yeah, like music in general. Um,
my favorite genre is like pop music.
Like I love anything that could be
considered pop because it changes with the
times, but you have these mega
stars, you know what I mean?
Who just transcend like,
like it's, it's, it's like,
so there'd be, they're larger
than life, like Michael Jackson,
you know what I'm saying? Like he's bigger
than just music, you know what I mean?
Like, and you, you become a legend,
like as time goes on,
but like to be a living legend,
like living in those times and to be
around those people and to really hear
their music and experienced
them and shit like that.
I feel like that shit is crazy and it's
like a, it's a gift. Like for the fans,
it's a gift to be that person.
It's a responsibility as well,
but just like to be the one like,
like Beyonce, you know what I mean?
Like that shit is crazy to me
to be the one. Yeah. When
Michael Jackson was the one,
when there was no one before,
there was no real one like him.
I mean there was all
this and that's about it.
There was other ones that were big.
They were very popular, very famous.
But Michael Jackson Trans,
he transcended so hard.
I was listening to Wbcn in Boston
as a rock and roll station
and they were like,
I know there's a rock roll station,
but this song is so fucking good,
we're going to play it anyway. And
they played Michael Jackson. Yep.
And we were like, wow. They
had been performance as a kid.
So he worked his whole life to get to be
what it will look like 30 or something
like that. When he [inaudible]
up, there was nobody,
there was no roadmap for him. Nah,
that shit is amazing. Amazing.
And he did,
you know,
funk music and he went through disco and
you know what I mean? It's just like,
wow. Yeah. Yeah man.
I would've loved to have seen him live
before the controversy. Right. You know,
just to just experience him as an artist
without having anything attached to it.
Yeah. What he did or didn't
do, I don't know what he did.
You know, I have no idea.
Doesn't look good,
but I would have loved to have seen
him without the burden of that filming.
It must've been insane.
And the only just to,
just to see like he
was like a [inaudible].
It needs to be a different word for work,
you know,
because sometimes it's not work.
It's a passion. Projects just,
it's way better than work.
He's a different,
you shouldn't have a different
word for a star. Yup.
Cause he was like a supernova. He was
some rare thing. Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
That might happen once every hundred
years. Yeah, yeah, yeah. For sure.
There's legends like Elton
John, Rod Stewart, and fucking,
there's all kinds of legends.
But then there was Michael Jackson,
he was above all of them.
It was a mania. Yeah.
Kids would dress like them. Everybody
wanted to wear those thriller jackets.
Right.
There's an art to it.
I feel like every musician has a choice.
Like if they want to go
there with it. Right. Yeah.
I feel like Elton Elton John's and like
even like prints and shit like that,
they stay true to exactly who they were.
Not that Michael Jackson
didn't stay true to who he was,
but he put himself into,
he put himself out there for the world.
He did everything. He had
cartoons, he had sneakers, he had,
he did everything, you know, the Beatles
music. Yeah. He bought, yeah. Like,
you know what I mean?
Fucking dude on the other people's music.
But like, yeah. Hell yeah. He was
doing hell of Shit. Yeah. I just think,
um, there was no roadmap for
the poor guy. Right. You know,
when you're living in that fantasy world
that nobody else can understand. Right.
And there's no one before you, and then
everywhere you go, people are screaming.
He never had a break down. There was no
breaks. There's nothing. You can do it.
He couldn't do anything. No. Hell Nah.
Hell Nah. Nothing normal. Nothing.
That's crazy. That was up
the, I'm wondering if that,
what that would be like until like if
Michael Jackson came around today and he
didn't exist before,
he would for sure be a huge star.
But I wonder if it would
be as crazy because there's
so many more stars now than
there were back then
because of the Internet,
because it's just more
venues now for musicians,
for basically everyone, for Comedians,
for everyone, right. There's more outlets.
So because there's more outlets
is more famous people. Right.
I wonder if he would be as it would if
it would be as insane because back when
he was that famous, it wasn't like
anyone that was parallel, not even close.
Yeah, man. What do you do? Listen
to old stuff. Yeah, I listened to,
I like a,
yeah,
we,
I'll do like nineties R and B now.
I like a funk music or like,
like Bootsy Collins. All right.
I love Jimmy Hendricks. He's
one of my favorites. I like, uh,
Curtis may feel, uh, Marvin Gaye, uh,
freaking and cooling again. Fucking, uh,
I listen to everything,
but I like a lot of the older soul music,
like the spinners, uh, Patti
Labelle, you know what I'm saying?
But I was raised on everything.
My Dad listened to Bob Marley.
He listened to a freaking, uh, oh,
we used to listen to a lot of sting
and the police may, I love staying.
He's one of my favorites. Um, just all
the jams, you know what I'm saying?
Like the classic shit, like if you could
put on any song, like for real, for real.
And I fuck with it because I listened
to a lot of different music and yeah.
Oh yeah. Marvin gay man. Yeah. He's one
of my favorite. He was phenomenal. Yeah.
Marvin Gaye was really good and
it's tragic story. That was crazy.
His Dad shot him. It's so
crazy. I, I dated a girl once.
This girl was so nuts and, uh, I, we
were talking about shotgun. No, no, no.
We're talking about Marvin Gaye.
You know what I'm saying?
Like the second so insane that
his dad shot him and she said,
imagine what a piece of shit he had to
be for his dad to shoot him. Yeah. Right.
And I was like, what? I go,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Why would you assume he's the Bz chicken?
His Dad fuck shot.
If he's a piece of shit bothers his dad,
just get away from that shooting him.
His Dad's a piece of shit like,
but it was amazing.
She was like instantly thinking
he's a piece of shit. I'm like,
I don't get your logic really.
Someone with a good dad different because
she's someone who grew up with a good,
she's still loved her dad. She was
close with her dad. Yeah. So I was like,
Oh God, I'm, no. My Dad said to me,
I'm like that that shot him
because he was Marvin Gaye.
He's probably upset that his son
had become Marvin Gaye. Truth.
Imagine being Marvin Gaye too weird.
All your songs are like the best music to
fuck to. Yeah. Yeah. And he didn't have,
there was nothing,
there was no slide into the DM now.
They had to find them physically, but he
seemed like kind of like a faithful guy.
Like he seemed like he would find like
one chick fuck her right album about it.
That would be a good narrative.
I think it's hard for those
dudes if they're singing
about fucking all the time.
It's coming
their way to tsunami. They usually like
just want to fuck one girl like that.
Right. Those, those love songs. Yeah,
exactly. Like when the music's dark,
like easy either. You know what I
mean? Like he's fucking mad bitches.
He wasn't talking about like, like
just one like right. Know what I mean?
He wasn't on his Marvin Gay Shit.
I remember he said sexual healing.
You know what I mean? When you get
that feeling he needs sexual healing.
Like the shit made him feel
better. Yeah. When he was with her.
That's a big difference
in the Nwa first album.
I think difference in the message,
sexual healing.
There's some shit from like the early
gangster rap days you listen to today,
you're like, whoa man. Yup.
This is, this is crazy stuff.
I remember it at the time when it was
first coming out and no one knew like no
one could understand there was no music
like this before and then all the sudden
you have ice tea.
Yeah.
That was before they bought up the
freaking parental advisory on there.
They made that because like it's like
your parents make sure y'all check this
out before your kids get it.
It was Al Gore's wife who was tipper Gore.
It was,
she was the one who was in charge. She was
like, she was leading the charge. Yeah.
Against, I think it was her.
Make sure I'm right about that.
Is that I'm not mad at that. That may
rap music better. You think so? Oh yes.
Like made it more dangerous. Oh,
he put the, the extreme, the shoot.
They were trying like a rated r movie.
They were trying to ban some stuff though.
They were trying to ban
some amusing like uh Oh God,
that was Florida. Florida's crazy.
Don't fuck around in Florida.
Catch you in Florida.
They arrest people for anything.
You can get arrested for absurdity
and boring. I'm straight, I'm good.
I'm not going to Florida.
Florida was a, that's my goal,
but I'm not going crazy in Florida.
Broward county. Yeah. Yeah.
Just don't get arrested for
swearing. Yeah. You know what I mean?
That's what they got two live
crew for explicit lyrics. Yeah.
Fuck. I'm good on all that
shit about that. Right? Yeah.
Those guys would like to
Lenny Bruce of wraps, right?
Like Lenny Bruce is the guy when he got
arrested a bunch of times for stand up
comedy because he wouldn't change
his words and his, you know,
swearing on stage in front of court.
That was two I've crew.
And as you going to jail for
like for rap? Yeah. That's crazy.
That's crazy for saying
some for saying something.
Somebody doesn't like it so they
want to put you in a cage. Wow.
Cause they don't like how you're saying
wow. They don't like what you're saying.
They don't like how you're saying it.
Could you arrest someone if
they just said that somewhere?
What if they're in the comfort of their
own house and they said the things that
are in that cause that illegal. Could
you yell it out the window? Yeah.
Could I drive down the road yelling out
the window. Right. Should be able to.
It should be able to see you man.
How the fuck are you to tell people
that can't do that. But then Florida,
they're like nope, obscenity
for rap. Florida is like
its own world though. Like,
that's why when shit goes down, it's
like, all right, and then this Florida.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. It is.
It's so its own world that it's
being overrun with invasive species.
[inaudible] a lady got attacked by a car.
A alligator just yesterday. Here. What?
That Jamie. I feel like that happens
all the time down there all the time.
More often than not.
More often rather than not
necessarily in a good way.
Set more often now than before
because there's a lot of them. Yeah.
I could imagine being engaged or not
having nowhere to go scan it into Florida
money. Eat some stupid lady like
clear. This is dumb and slow, bitch.
I've been around for a long ass
fucking time. I'm hungry as fuck. Yeah,
Florida's fucking crazy. Let's eat and
you just look at that lady and like,
she's so annoying. Yeah. Maybe no one
will even notice. I don't even eat ladies,
but I'm going to do it today. They
dogs. They love the people's dogs.
That's what's fucked up. I get snack
[inaudible] now. Yeah. I love dogs though.
So I don't know.
But if I was at gator,
a dog would be a good snack for sure.
I was a good meal per four.
Prefer dog than the lady.
Yeah.
People have closed on exact adjuster
sneakers and shit, man. Yeah.
Yeah. Choose. It tastes good. If
you didn't live in California,
what state would you live in?
Hm.
If I did live in Cali. What stayed
with, I live in not Georgia,
not Florida. Not
Pennsylvania. Not New York.
Not New York, Huh? Nah. Too
crazy. That'd be upstate New York.
Ah Man. Maybe upstate. That's
going to call it though.
Kinda worry about tickets to get.
Fuck takes fuck text and then everybody
gets Lyme disease out there. Yeah.
Damn. I don't, I don't know.
I never thought about that
with the shit hits the fan.
I love California tsunami rolls over or
maybe I'll go to Australia every time
I'm on the highway nowadays and
it's jammed up bumper to bumper.
I just say imagine if something happened.
This is just Thursday,
just irregular Thursday and it's bumper
to bumper magic or some shit went.
That'd be fucked up. People wouldn't
know what to do when it rains out here.
People don't know what to do. Panic, they
slam into each other. This guy to drive.
It's like dog is just rain.
It's just water coming out the sky.
Oh Jesus Christ. It's a
strange place to live. Right.
Cause people aren't tested out here by
climate. Yeah. Yeah. On the east coast.
They're tested by climate. Yeah.
Yup. That winter comes, that's snowy.
Wind comes you gotta gotta
fuck pair guide. You got to
winterize your car. Yeah.
Got To get snow tires. Yeah. That's for
fuckers out here. Don't know about that.
They don't know. Hell No. They don't know.
350 tornadoes last week where you just
heard about the Midwest, wherever.
Tornado alley kind of shit. Yeah.
They got fucked up, man. Yeah.
That was like Ohio. And
where else? Kentucky.
I think just handing out tornadoes there.
He got hit hard.
Yeah man. I mean, I don't know if that's
really because of climate change.
Those are ramping up,
but if they ramp up in an unprecedented
levels like that and it becomes
impossible to live in Ohio or Kentucky
or anywhere where there's tornadoes,
you imagine how nuts that is.
If we find out that the center
of the country is just tornado,
like a tornado bowling areas,
both fill with tornadoes in Florida,
you just dodging hurricanes
most of the year.
They just get lucky if it doesn't happen
where you are. Yeah. You get lucky. Yeah.
You're a dick sticking out into the ocean
and it's right where all the tornadoes
get formed or all the
hurricanes get formed there.
Right. It's like warmer waters. Right.
Here we go. We'll get started right here.
Yep.
Fuck hurricanes.
I've been in a little baby hurricane
before and I was living in Boston,
which is pretty far away from the ocean
in terms of where my house was and it
still, it was like wow. And that was
a little baby one. It was nothing.
By the time it got to us,
it was nothing.
I lived in Japan for two years and
they used to have some crazy fucking
earthquakes over there. Oh really? Why
you were there? Earthquakes and typhoons.
You saw both? Fuck yeah. Hell
yeah. Like what was the earthquake?
Black bad. You never been in
one here and the a baby ones.
I've been in like a 5.5 bro.
Like I'm talking about whole room,
just shaking like it's like
a ride at universal. Like,
cause you see shit and moving. It's
like damn, is this really happening?
And this shit happens bro. Like the
earthquakes over there and an insane wow.
Yup. And they get some crazy rain
like one of the typhoons come.
That shit gets really violent
too. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The Japanese or you know,
they, they, they hold it down. What
were you doing living over there?
My parents are military. Um, my
mom was in there for a little bit,
but then she got out and then my dad
was in there. He got out but remarried.
So that's how I stayed in the
military thing was my stepmom.
And uh, I would move, we would
live on base, you know what I mean?
For like two years or whatever. And
then I will move back with my mom. Wow.
What was it like living in Japan? I
said it was crazy. Like it was fun.
I lived there in the late nineties,
so it was like when
technology was first changing,
like music was just now going into
mp3s and shit like that. So, um,
there was that, um, Pokemon
was really popular over there.
Uh, it was fun. Like just
being a kid, like running
around fucking it up in Japan.
It was cool, man. It was
funny as hell. That's, uh,
an interesting little extra level to
your brain, right? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I grew up those two years in a
completely different kind of culture.
Totally have a different understanding
of what's possible. Right. 100%.
I think that's so big for kids,
man. Show them shit. Yeah. Yeah.
Helped out a lot for sure. Um,
yeah, it was cool. How's do right?
Like as far as your perspective,
it's been around.
I've only been in Tokyo for a few days,
only once where I was like,
this is one of the trippiest place I've
ever been in my life. So interesting.
It was crazy. Live in there.
It was wild. Like no TV,
like regular TV. They don't got
any like American TV stations.
So for two years I was just
like disconnected. Yeah.
Like I didn't have shit.
Yeah, it was crazy.
So this was before Netflix and everything
too, right? And more youtube. Wow.
Yeah. That's amazing. And then that
was probably really good for you.
Not Sucked.
I couldn't watch wrestling,
but it was really good for your brain.
No, no. It takes up. I need that.
I need my entertainment man. Fuck that.
I needed to be a part of the world.
I couldn't buy all the CDS and shit
that everybody was listening to. It was,
it was whack. Did you learn
to speak Japanese? This a
little bit. Yeah. Yeah, Yup.
Wow. Baby Japanese just to get around
and shit. But I forgot it though.
You forgot it all. Not all of it
will. It'll come back if I like,
you know what I mean?
You run me through it,
but I can't sit here and say no Japanese
words. How hard was it to learn?
It wasn't difficult. No, Nah, Nah. It's
not difficult reading it is difficult.
Oh yeah.
Because they have symbols or characters,
so it's like one character
means like three of our words.
Um, wow. Yeah. Yup.
And then they have like three
different styles of writing it too.
So it's like we have print and cursive.
They don't know three different ones.
Oh, that sounds so annoying.
Yeah, it's weird with the,
on one hand you don't want it to go
away because it's an ancient language.
But the other hand you're like, can
you clean this up? Simplify this shift.
Honestly think they got it down pat.
You know what I'm saying?
They only want us to have fucking know
that shit. You know what I'm saying?
Like at the end of the day, they're
like, we'll learn English if we want to,
but if you want to learn Japanese,
it's going to be difficult, bro.
I want to learn some
Asian language because I,
I'm fascinated by reading
like a Twitter messages from,
you know, how much many more characters
they had. Yeah. They can write books.
140 characters. It's like how many
words is that though? Yeah, no,
that's a lot of fucking words.
If it's two 82 80 of those Asian
where there's Chinese or Japanese,
those little symbols that it's
a lot of talking man. Yeah.
It's hard to put like the ingredients
on shit. Oh yeah, I'd imagine.
Do they have symbols for
numbers or just use the numbers?
I forgot what the numbers look like.
I think it's symbols. Really? Yeah.
I don't imagine that. It's like one,
two and three. Oh Wow. Right. Yeah.
Take something. Yeah. I never even
thought of that. Yeah. You're like,
what does what? What is,
uh, let's go with Japanese.
Does Japanese,
does the Japanese language have
symbols that red out of your numbers?
Like you would write the letter, the
letters, t, h, r, e, e for three.
Like that. Like you would write
three or you'd be the number three.
Do they have that in Japanese?
Not because Japanese is like each,
each knee son, she, oh, uh,
there's different, different,
whole different words for it.
So it was like, one is Ichi.
So however the symbol,
however you spell that in Japanese,
I, I'm starting to cut her.
Remember what it looks like now.
Do you think if you could
move back there right now,
you just get right back into the
swing of things after awhile? Sure.
[inaudible]
David Lee Roth moved their van Halen,
the lead singer of on, he moved down
there and uh, took Kendo lessons.
He lived there for like more than a year.
I would probably appreciate it more now
as an adult. Do you think so? Yeah. Yup.
Cause as a kid you kind of just want to
run wild and do everything that you see
on TV, but he must be annoyed. You
were stuck there. It was kind of weird.
You know what I mean?
I was 13 like wanting to like go crazy.
It was fun for a little while. But yeah,
you want to go back home and shit. Like,
you know what I mean? Of course.
But as an adult I feel like I would,
I would benefit a lot more from it.
There you go.
So at this stage of your career,
when you're,
when you're looking at like what you're
putting down w w when you're making
albums,
when you're putting together your music,
like what excites you the most about it?
Um,
I'm a huge fan of music in general,
so I get just inspired off of like
production and shit like that.
Like the newest producers and
shit. Like, cause I like to go out,
I like to enjoy myself, I like to have
fun. So whatever's popping like at that,
that time,
whatever the sound is,
whether it's west coast inspired
or if it's down south inspired,
I'm just interested in finding my
own way of doing what's new and what,
what my fans would love
from me because I'm like,
as a music person,
you want something new every time.
You don't want the old shit all the time,
you could go by that.
So I just love creating and
just coming up with what's new,
you know what I mean?
Like I work with the newest producers.
I work with the newest artists I work
with, you know what I mean? I try to,
I try to make my shit sound different
every time. I always tell my engineer,
I'm like, Yo, let's fuck
with this shit sonically.
So it don't sound the
same as the last album.
Like come up with new ad libs or just
different shit that just kind of keep it
fresh. Still do what people know
me for, you know what I mean?
But it's like just coming up with new
ways of doing that. I get excited.
That's awesome to hear.
I love it when someone loves what they're
doing and it comes out great. Thanks.
It's beautiful to see.
It really is.
And that to me is one of
the most inspiring things
that I get at any artists.
It's like hearing them talk
about their process. Right.
In a why I always get jazzed up.
I love this.
It's crazy for me because like there's
different ways to to do what what I do.
Like,
I have so many ways I could sit there and
just come up with some shit like brand
new or I have like this,
the oil commercial with my son wears.
Like there's a team of people who like
come up with what could be the best for
me and I just do that shit and then it
just goes crazy. You know what I mean?
It's like,
see you again is one of my biggest songs.
And that song had like eight
different people on it.
But I wrote two verses that the
person who made the original song,
I wrote two versus for it that they
love more than anybody else's song,
I mean anybody else's.
So they gave me the whole record and
it ended up being my host. I mean my,
one of my biggest songs,
you know what I mean? Wow.
So it's like the process of just like
putting yourself in the situation and just
being like, all right, cool. Let's
work. That's beneficial. As, as,
as beneficial as being, you know
what I mean? A creative just, okay,
I'm gonna do what I do.
You know what I mean?
Sometimes you got to step outside
of that and just use your talents.
It's like being an actor or,
you know what I mean?
Like you just fill in that
spot that people need you lit.
And I'm kind of at that point in my career
because I worked so hard and grinded
and done so many things that
come up with so many, uh,
waves and ideas that didn't exist before.
Now I could use other people's ideas
and just be myself and still and get,
you know, really big effect. And
everybody is happy. Beautiful. Yep.
Dude, you live in the life. Got It nailed.
Oh, yeah. Congratulations. Oh yeah.
I had a great time talking to you, man.
I appreciate you too, Bro. Very nice.
Thank you, sir. Thank you all. Yeah.
Um, that's it. Everybody. Bye. Yup.
Awesome.
[inaudible].